All Right,
we're live gentlemen.
What's up?
Hey now,
thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Bigger,
stronger,
faster.
It was a,
it was a documentary that I could not.
Um,
there was so many people that we're
talking about it if you couldn't avoid
like having a conversation about it,
especially like in the UFC because so
many fighters have been accused of
taking performance enhancing drugs and
there's so many conversations about
that.
So,
uh,
I always wanted to talk to you guys and
I watched it again.
I watched,
I watched like the first half of it when
it first came out and I watched it all
again this morning to check it out.
Just get it.
Boy,
you're the first time or why didn't you
watch it?
All the way through,
but I don't remember.
I think it was on a plane and I think
the plane probably landed and I shut my
laptop and I never picked it up again.
It was one of those things.
Yeah.
What'd you think of it?
It's great.
Great Documentary and interesting and
honest.
It was really hilarious when you're
going over the,
uh,
people that like what's the number one
reason to go to the hospital and then
they're like,
aspirin,
fucking vitamin C and then below that
with steroids and then steroids was way
down.
I think the amount of deaths,
it's like steroids deaths or like
slightly above water drinking water.
There's no,
there's no real proof to link to link
anything scientifically,
you know,
you can have a anecdotal evidence on a
lot of things,
but nothing scientifically links
steroids that these deaths,
this is a real problem with some people.
They don't want to hear that and they
did.
They don't want to hear it because they
don't.
There's like a,
there's a narrative that we're being
taught in this country or that we're
being told to embrace that narrative is
steroids are for cheaters and cheaters,
losers and losers on American.
But as you highlighted in your movie
over and over and over again,
all these examples of different athletes
that were caught with performance
enhancing drugs was the guy from the
Tour de France,
whether it was Carl Lewis,
the Carlos thing was fucking hilarious
because a lot of people don't know when
Ben Johnson got tested positive for
steroids,
they stripped him of his metal.
Carl Lewis tested positive for
amphetamines.
Yeah.
It wasn't supposed to run.
So that's the whole thing is crazy.
I mean,
they're all doped up,
but like you said about the narrative
that they want you to believe the
narrative doesn't come from health
problems.
The narrative comes from,
you know,
nobody's concerned about the health of
the athlete.
We say that,
uh,
but nobody really concerned about the
health of the athlete.
They're concerned about an unfair
advantage.
Yeah.
They're concerned about someone being
able to do what we suspected the
Russians were doing back in the fifties.
And that was really enlightening to when
you were talking to that guy that was
saying that they,
they had found out about it from the
Russians doing it at 19 fifties.
And from then on they were doping and
over shots of vodka,
they were actually hanging out with the
Russian strength coach and he was,
you know,
a little loose,
loosey Goosey and he sort of slipped up
and it's like,
yeah,
we're given our guys testosterone.
So as soon as I got out of the bag Dr
Ziglar raced home and he created Diana
Ball,
which was even a stronger steroid then
was currently available on the market
and they started testing guys with like
five milligrams of Diana Ball.
And of course they found other ways to
get it through the testing facility or
however they were getting their hands on
it once it was manufactured.
And that's when it became the wild west.
Basically.
It was like people started taking 20
milligrams and getting way stronger.
And it's kind of crazy because if you
know,
if you want to get better at something,
people don't have a problem with people
using certain means where people don't
have problem with someone to go into a
supplement store and purchasing
something that doesn't work.
But as soon as you take something that's
powerful,
people are like,
well,
wait a second.
We don't want you to doing that.
Good.
I was always tell people the strongest
shit I ever took.
They made illegal but used to be able to
buy the GNC.
It was called Mag 10.
Do you remember that snow?
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That stuff.
I took that shit for like whatever it
was like six weeks.
I gained like 10 pounds.
I was jacked up all the time.
It was like a bunch of pills.
You have to take like 10 pills.
And after it was over,
my Dick died.
Like it got hit with a media was
useless.
It was useless.
The thing is,
it took me for my testosterone to come
back and it's like,
oh,
this is steroids.
Like real steroids.
You could buy a GNC.
They made it illegal.
Those drugs are more dangerous than the
actual real testosterone and all kinds
of stuff to the fuck was in danger.
I just bought it because it was legal.
Probably a lot of sodium,
a lot of those pills.
Uh,
what they do is they'll give you a,
a huge surge of estrogen as well for the
girl to now they did.
And I got lucky,
but you know,
that's what one of the guys was on the
US power lifting team with,
uh,
Bruce Jenner thinks happened to gender
and he believes that.
Well,
first of all he said he knows that they
had gender pumped full of steroids.
He said we were all on steroids.
He goes,
Jana was absolutely pumped full of
steroids.
And he said that was what started his
transition.
This is where I'm heading.
Maybe if you drop off a little bit to
stay on dude,
you know,
that's,
that's interesting.
But mark and I had this talk the other
day and I think that,
um,
this whole like gender issue and
transgender and all these different
things like,
I don't know how much that's linked to
testosterone levels are not like that.
I don't know the,
if there's that many definitive studies
on like whether your testosterone,
like if you have a high estrogen level,
just because somebody is going to be
trained,
they don't have testosterone levels.
Yeah,
there's a lot of people that are gay
that are very high testosterone.
Later,
people can kick ass to there.
Okay.
But,
but those are gay.
They're not,
they don't identify as female that there
is a difference.
I don't know how that actually
correlates.
I haven't read the studies on that
stuff,
but I think it's probably,
it's difficult for us to understand as
to understand what it's like to be a
woman.
It's like,
it's like you don't get it.
You don't get any.
Like,
like they probably don't get what it's
like to not want to be a woman right
now.
You're like,
ah,
I'm good.
He's like,
are you sure you don't want to be a
woman?
Like,
I'm good,
I'm good.
Well,
good luck.
And the power lifting world,
uh,
in the,
you know,
the world power lifting,
it's been sort of turned on its ear by a
guy named Matt Kroc is that.
It's ski marks can tell you a little bit
more about him.
But uh,
he had been friends with him for about a
decade.
Um,
I've known about his issue for about six
or seven years now and he's actually
going to on my show coming up soon,
but you know,
he's a transgender and he's,
you know,
it's ruined relationships for them many
times over.
He's got three kids,
he's a good father,
he's a good person,
he's a good dude or female.
That's good woman.
She's a good woman.
Um,
but uh,
you know,
the issue is,
is really interesting and that's why I
want to like talk to him and try to help
people just better understand it because
people get so mad.
That's the thing I don't get as he is a,
I do understand voicing your opinion and
saying,
fuck man,
that's weird.
Like,
that makes sense to me.
But people actually getting mad and
having a committing hate crimes and
stuff.
To me it's just disgusting.
I don't,
I'm not on board with that.
Yeah,
it is disgusting and I just,
I got to think that it comes from their
family,
from the way they're raised by their
parents are ignorant.
That's the only thing that makes any
sense.
I just think that we're moving past
that.
I think there's more awareness and more
acceptance for those sorts of issues
that people have,
that every country worries about.
Some fucked up shit.
There's a lot worse going on.
Steroids,
who cares everyday,
everyday.
Another cop shooting somebody and we're
worried about concerned ourselves so
much more with the tabloid media than we
do with the,
with what's really going on in this
country.
Well,
the cops shooting part,
you know,
it's a horrible thing,
but cops on steroids is something that
people don't talk about too much.
Uh,
it's kind of hilarious when you see cops
busting people for steroids because we
all know anybody who knows people that
take steroids knows that cops are on
steroids.
Absolutely.
Giant chunk of them and busted our
brother would steroids and they're
probably on it when they were busted and
confiscated every cop in poughkeepsie
where we're from,
got huge.
They had,
they took like a thousand pills,
a Diana ball from him.
And next thing you know that cops are
walking around all jack.
Well,
they had A.
I had talked to a guy who was a cop I
used to workout with and he had a
rational explanation.
He's like,
look man.
He goes,
it's fucking gross out there.
it's dangerous as fuck and you got to be
on top of your game and you want to have
an edge.
Right?
Meanwhile,
dude was five slash 70 weight to 50.
I'm like,
you've got a couple of edges,
edges all over your body,
so fucking jacked.
That's how do you even move like that?
That's not very well.
Well,
someone would have to do is get ahold of
him and hang on.
You got to do with a guy like that as
ride the bull will send them.
Look,
if you taught those guys what you know
in Jujitsu,
they'd be much more effective than
taking steroids,
but that's probably the easier route.
Right?
I would help,
but the real.
The reality is you're dealing with guns
and knives and shit like that.
No matter how big you are,
it doesn't even really matter,
right?
No.
You definitely should know how to defend
yourself physically.
One hundred percent.
Every cop should be a black belt in
something,
you should know what it's like to be in
a wild melee with another person who's
trying to kill you with their hands,
but that's not going to protect you from
guns and knives and all that and gun
defense stuff like that's,
that's an art in and of itself.
Like,
you know,
there's some guys who are experts in
guns away from people and Shit.
But good luck with all the major
differences between like UFC and pride.
Pride.
I don't think they really had rules.
Right.
They definitely had rules.
They had no elbows and that was just
mentioned testing wise.
Oh,
testing wise.
Yeah.
No,
they didn't have rules at all.
In fact,
they specifically said on their
contracts that there was no,
no test steroids.
Uh,
ensign.
Anyway.
Who's one of the fighters from pride?
Great guy fought in UFC as well.
He,
um,
he did this whole thing about it where
he came on the podcast and explain like
the verbatim contract.
It said we are not going to test.
You forced her meaning like,
go ahead and do your thing.
Yeah.
Well,
they encouraged it,
buddy of mine who was,
he would fight in America,
American one 70 and they wanted him to
fight in Japan.
He went over there and had some meetings
that you'll one 85 and he's like,
but I don't wave one any five.
I weigh 180 right now.
Is acknowledged this throats again wit
like they were like really sold on him
being one of the five.
They wanted big Americans.
They wanted everyone to look like Mark
Kerr.
Remember my.
It was amazing as smashing machine.
That's smashing machine as a documentary
filmmaker.
That was my favorite documentary.
I think the sale is to we ever.
It's an amazing documentary and for
folks who don't know what it's about,
it's about Mark Kerr who was at the time
one of the most dangerous mma fighters
and more like a guy who you would look
at and you'd say,
well that is what an MMA fighter should
look like.
Two hundred 60 pounds fucking Jack to
the tits.
Just giant and smashing people.
But they caught him.
There he is right there at his prime.
What a fucking shit man.
Yeah,
that's a good picture.
They caught him right when he slid.
They caught.
They literally caught him on top before
he'd slipped and then went into this mad
fucking painkiller slide.
Absolutely.
It happens to everybody.
I mean that's what happened in the world
of pro wrestling,
which were like really closely
associated with all these guys.
You didn't hear about the wrestlers
dying and everything.
It's not necessarily the steroids,
it's a deadly cocktail that they're all
doing it.
Steroids are a big part of it,
but that's the steroids.
It's tiny in comparison to the head
injured is important to point out that,
that they're not safe.
You know,
like I think sometimes people that take
them are like,
fuck yeah man,
take steroids.
They definitely have their,
their drawbacks and there are
definitely,
it's a drug and it's an illegal drug,
you know,
so that always needs to be done dose.
It's well,
right.
You know,
there's people that are gonna take a
little bit and be fine or there's people
that are going to go off the rails and
like there was a dude that we knew that
was a detour Belfort's trainer in the
nineties and he died really young.
She died like 32 or 33.
We used to call them garden hoses
because he would work out.
He would be purple and it's fucking arms
veins.
Curtis left purple.
Yeah.
They call him,
call the Barney at the gym.
They'd call him Barney because they're
so purple.
He was nicest guy.
The sales guy.
Really great guy.
And um,
and veto or at the time was Jack Jack.
He was training at golds Venice.
He almost got to Jack Memory,
came in,
smoked everybody.
Then all of a sudden he got like kind of
too big.
When he fought randy,
he was too big and it was like 2:40
when he fought randy and he had no gas
tank.
He was using specimen when he was
younger.
When he was 19,
when he was 200 pounds.
He was like the perfect size because
Vito has like a size eight foot.
He's not a big guy like his hands are
fairly small too,
but he's just a spectacular athletes.
It's amazing.
He's done it for so long and believable.
I know it is and it's.
It's a really.
It's an interesting point because v tour
for the last year and a half was on
testosterone replacement last like two
years and had the most spectacular
results of his career.
It was really crazy to see a guy who had
been fighting since 1997 in the UFC and
he's knocking out Michael Bisping.
He's knocked out Luke rockhold,
Dan Henderson.
He's we'll kicking people in the head
with the way he was doing.
It was just fucking crazy to watch.
He had kicked three of the best fighters
in the world and did it with muscles
grown out of his fucking teeth mean just
legal in the UFC was legal.
It's honestly therapeutic use then.
Yeah,
but now it's a lot of came in and went,
Whoa,
hold the fuck up.
What's going on here?
First of all,
they had guys.
There were guys that were in their
twenties that had been prescribed it
for.
Yeah.
And they're like,
well,
what happened?
Why do you have a load test?
And most of them it's because the
steroid use and we all know that there's
a way of manipulating those tests and
maybe some are overtrained not sleeping
well on top of 100 percent.
And if you don't think those tests get
manipulated into like what you'd need to
do in bigger,
stronger,
faster.
I show you how to get human growth
hormone and basically,
you know,
go to your doctor and do this and that.
And the way that you take the test was
you had to like pee in this bag
basically all day long.
And then you take a sample of that
urine.
Uh,
but you know,
the way that I did it was I only,
I only took the urine from like two
samples that were taken at night when
your growth hormone is the lowest.
So my growth hormone looked like it came
from a guy who's 125 years old.
They're like,
oh my God,
you have no growth when I'm on your
ticket in the morning.
It would have and balance it out with
during the day would have been normal.
It would have been normal,
but it was really low,
so I just wanted the doctor to give me
growth hormone to see if they would do
it for the movie.
Well,
the also they say if you eat a very
large fatty meal like cheeseburgers and
fries and shit,
like a big burger,
like right before you take the test,
like within an hour,
the test shit just plummets.
Your test plummets,
your growth plummets.
Everything just goes,
oh,
there's,
there's ways to beat all these tests.
Even even the guys that are beating the
test,
uh,
to compete.
Lance Armstrong,
all these guys are strong lies.
A good documentary too.
Saw that was fucking incredible.
Well,
Jeff,
mind boggling.
The guy who busted Lance Armstrong is
going to be on my podcast next week.
I fucking can't.
I had a great comment.
He,
the UFC,
hired him to try to clean up the sport.
I don't know what it's like going to a
hoarder's house like you need to hire.
The other guy will eat off this floor,
hire a Ferrari guy.
The guy that was the Lance Armstrong
coach I was trying to do,
no matter what you do,
the cheaters will always be ahead
of the guys that are trying to catch
them.
It's just a cat and mouse game.
It's been going on forever.
Yeah,
well they were kind of ahead.
Now what they're doing now is they're,
you know,
the way they make testosterone.
Apparently they do something with yams.
That's how they make it.
Do you know the Mexican Wild Yams?
Yeah.
Well now do that thing where it's
derived from or something.
Yeah.
Well now they figured out how to do it
with animals and they have made a
bioidentical testosterone that's.
You can't differentiate.
We just spoke about a stem cells.
Now,
stem cells aren't going to be a human,
but stem cells are going to allow you a
Vito Belfort right now.
Now that he can't do the testosterone
replacement,
he gets stem cells done to all of his
existing injuries.
You know,
he basically got a clean slate and he's,
and he's back to normal.
I know where to draw the line.
I guess built over time,
you know,
a baseball pitcher can pitch 10 more
years.
How,
how is,
how is that going to affect the future
of sports with the records and all these
things like who can hit the most home
runs and who can,
you know,
play the longest and all you need.
It's like there's a word that's a banned
word.
Steroids is like,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a negative word.
My word will never be polished up.
Granted me and it's like the Barry Bonds
Shit with mark mcgwire all over
Congress.
By the way.
That was one of my favorite parts of the
documentary was watching those dummies
in Congress.
It was amazing to see.
And Joe Biden talk about memory when I
was a good athlete.
I thought at the fuck you were,
you were never a good athlete.
I would like to that sir.
They took it away from me and it wasn't
by God given talent,
like third string baseball player,
like community college,
whatever he was save it,
but whatever.
He was just shut your mouth.
Yeah,
exactly.
The thing was like,
they bring up these baseball players and
string them up before Congress.
It becomes this huge media circus.
Everybody loves to see that.
I'll look at their,
you know,
they're pointing out all these guys and
they're the bad guys and you have guys
like Mark Maguire up there looking like
mark McGuire said,
steroids is bad.
It's a bad message.
Don't do them.
It's like,
this is people.
These are,
these are these heroes too.
These kids up there that are completely
looking like idiots and there's a better
way to handle it,
you know?
Well,
it just seemed really frivolous that
they were in front of Congress for the.
They're getting too good at hitting the
ball with the stick.
We need to bring in all our leaders.
Right?
Same.
That doesn't even seem real.
It seems like a good plot in the movie.
Even in swimming,
they made suits a few years ago.
They got rid of them right away.
It's a speedo company made a suit that
makes you swim faster and as soon as
they did that they were like,
Whoa,
we don't want you to swim in that fast.
So they got rid of them.
So it was like a body suit,
like your whole body as the body suit.
So like a wetsuit.
Yeah,
I think it helped increase like buoyancy
a little bit and just helped you kind of
glide through the pool faster.
That's pretty dope.
We're got one of those.
Well I guess the,
the issue with it was a,
it's expensive and so they were like,
oh,
it might price some people out of it or
whatever.
I was like,
I don't really even understand what that
is.
All these sports end up being pretty
expensive.
Come on man.
The amount of money that's involved in
training for the Olympics for swimming,
things that are going on now with
training are insane.
You know,
I did my second film,
did a movie called trophy kids and it's
about parents that push their kids in
sports and that was on hbo and the thing
that is so crazy now is the way that
parents have access to all these things
we didn't have,
like you'll go to a,
you know,
a,
a baseball camp and they have like this
Nike makes his hand eye coordination
thing that you wouldn't believe how it
tells you,
like,
what position your kid should play.
It tells you,
you know,
and,
and parents are actually going and
getting genetic testing on their kid.
They swab the inside of their kids a
cheek and they send it off to this
company and it,
it'll tell the parent what sports.
The kid will be good at.
This one,
they're like an infant.
So there's some crazy stuff going on
where,
uh,
you know,
technology is far exceeding like,
what we've been able to do before.
That's fucking madness.
Robbing your kids,
cheat to find out what sport they should
do.
Well,
there's a,
there's a um,
California cryobank.
It's like a sperm bank and it's a at
Ucla.
Don't get that infused with getting
frozen into the fuck the therapy.
Arthritis.
Wow.
Great job.
Joe Rogan was fucking shit.
Tastes great.
Anyway,
you can get,
um,
it actually shows a guy on HBO,
Real Sports.
He goes in and basically like they
custom order their kid and it's like
this fat,
what the hell?
It's like this fat Mexican guy.
He goes in and he says,
I want a kid just like me,
blue eyes,
blonde hair and big calves.
And it's like he looks nothing like the
guy.
So it's not his sperm as someone is
using a sperm donor because he couldn't
get his wife pregnant and they decide,
well we want our kid to be.
The father is similar,
similar to similar to me,
you know,
like athletic and outgoing and you know,
so they picked a six,
two blonde haired blue eyed kid with a.
and it actually says on the application,
huge gaps,
huge calves on the application.
What the fuck they,
they,
the California cryobank goes out and
they recruit players.
Uh,
I went to USC.
So I know it goes on at USC,
they go out and recruit players to make
extra money.
You can make 900 bucks a month or
something jerking off in a cup and
basically selling it to my parents.
It's a good deal.
Bad deal.
If you have rent,
you gotta pay it somehow.
Spring might be tainted probably.
Yeah.
They don't need to know that.
It's amazing.
It's an amazing phenomenon to see
parents now getting into like,
how am I going to help my kid sheet?
Well,
it's getting to the point also where
they're within a few years.
Have you heard of Crispr?
Do you know what Crispr is?
No.
There's a radio lab documentary they did
on it.
It's a or a radio lab episode rather.
It's all about um,
this new tool that they have for
engineering genetics and for splicing
genes and for adding traits or
subtracting traits.
And you know,
you,
you showed him the documentary,
the milestone and hypocrisies of doing
with these cows that make these cows
grow enormous amounts of muscle.
Well,
they're going,
first of all,
they could do it now to pigs and they're
going to be able to do it to people.
It's just a matter of when she's used to
be in a year.
Is it going to be in a decade?
It's going to happen.
If we live another 100 years of human
beings survive 100 years and the
asteroids don't blow us up or we don't
get hit by a fucking nuke.
We're gonna have myostatin inhibited
people that it looked like the hall
that's fucking crazy and it's going to
be nuts and they're going to live
longer.
That's what's even more fucked up.
What do you think about steroids in the
UFC?
Like what's your take on it?
Do you think they should be illegal or
monitored or.
Well,
I think she's gonna be a moot point once
you get to genetic engineering and I
think ultimately what steroids are,
is it's a form of engineering.
It's a form of biological engineering.
You're taking these substances and
you're adding people,
but as you pointed out in your,
in your documentary,
look at the guy who was the,
uh,
the,
the Tour de France guy that had this
oxygen tent,
these hyperbaric chamber to Chambers,
hyperbaric chambers.
What I do all the time,
the cryogenic freezing tanks,
all that shit is cheating.
I mean,
if you really want to look at it,
I take trt,
I'd take human growth hormone.
If I was competing in a somewhere that
wouldn't let me take that,
that would be considered cheating.
But for life,
like I'm like,
look,
if you're 48 years old and you're not
taking testosterone,
what do you hate?
Life.
You'd hate having energy started
throwing it away.
Like your immune system sucks.
You want to feel better,
look better.
Your body works better.
It's all about simple.
Optimizing what you already are.
And I think when people go beyond that,
that's when it becomes into like,
okay,
well that it's cheating.
I don't know why people think that,
but that's what it is.
It's like,
you know,
if you say,
well,
I'm on trt,
nobody really cares.
You know?
And the same commercials for tea,
our tea,
I don't know if you noticed,
but during the world series,
the same sport that they condemn for
steroids during the commercial break,
the first commercial.
Do you have low t?
Yeah.
No,
that's the very first commercial.
Hilarious.
I think that the issue with steroids
also for a lot of people is they believe
that it's going to get kids into them
and that the kids are gonna get sick or
they're going to get hurt or they're
gonna commit suicide.
Like the guy in the documentary had.
He was convinced that his kid who we had
on Lexapro,
who was a teenager,
you know what I mean?
He was convinced that with steroids that
made this kid commit suicide and
steroids very well may have played a
factor.
Abuse of anything is bad.
Whether it's abuse of alcohol,
there's a lot of different drugs,
painkillers that you can abuse that'll
make you suicidal.
Abuse of anything is bad.
So to blame it on one thing that guy had
this blanket thought in his mind,
he's just going to throw a blanket over
the problem.
The problem with steroids,
I don't even think you can blame it on
the Lexapro.
There's a deeper issue going on with
the,
with the child takes his own life.
He had,
he certainly had some issues and he also
didn't want to communicate with his
parents these issues too much and the
going on with that story that I put in
the movie and that was to protect the
company's gone.
Yeah.
Somebody loses a child.
I don't want to go into a family history
and all these other things that we found
out.
Um,
but yeah,
it's definitely hard for you for doing
that.
That's a,
they gave his father a million dollars
to go in front to,
to continue this education to continue a
lying to people basically.
Well that makes sense because that's why
he had this thought in his head,
like he wouldn't even consider the fact
that these kids are on psychoactive
drugs and he would.
Those had nothing to do with the fact
that his brain was fucked up.
Like,
come on man,
I got to know.
You don't know.
Those drugs are,
are dangerous to anybody.
There's a hundred years,
100 million people walking around on
psych meds and there's really no proof
that they actually work.
There's really no scientific proof that
they improve any sort of a problem with.
Is that true though?
Because they definitely do help some
people.
I think they definitely helped some
people,
but there's actually nothing.
There's no,
you know,
if you're looking at,
you can look at a,
like I said,
anecdotal evidence for anything.
I took this and I got bigger.
I got stronger,
um,
scientific proof now because there's no
real markers in the brain.
There's no test I can give you to see if
you feel better.
Right.
There's no depression tests.
Exactly.
I think,
yeah,
that's the issue there,
but there is,
there's a lot of evidence that Ssri
helped improve mood.
Right?
And they do,
yeah.
Yeah.
But there's also a,
a.
While they improve mood and some people,
a lot of people commit suicide on them
because they are so low down.
Like you'll see a person that's like
severely severely depressed.
They can't even get out of bed to kill
themselves.
And then they put them on an Ssri and
now they haven't just enough energy to
say fuck it,
you know,
that's what's so crazy.
Also with steroids though,
when you know that kid,
he just stopped cold Turkey,
you know,
he stopped the steroids right away and
then uh,
went on those other drugs,
but stopping him,
as you mentioned earlier,
like if you're 48 years old,
you want to get the energy boost from.
I'm just like coming off,
I'm actually a puts you at a lower state
than you ever were before.
So with that kid coming off him,
his testosterone levels are probably
low.
Is estrone levels probably came up.
It's probably just insanely depressed.
That does get you depressed.
And that's a big issue with fighters and
football players and people that have
had a lot of head injuries.
Dr Mark Gordon,
who was in your documentary for a brief
amount of time,
I saw his face in there.
He works with a lot of traumatic brain
injury people.
And one of the things that he finds
them,
they almost all have low testosterone.
Sure.
Something about getting the pituitary
gland rattled.
Whether it's through an IED or football
collisions or head kicks,
whatever the fuck it is.
Almost all of those guys have low
testosterone.
They just like super.
It's almost like getting kicked in the
balls.
You ever posed the question to this
athlete,
a Nevada state athletic commission,
you know,
the,
uh,
all these guys are getting pounded in
the head and the UFC,
they can,
they get punched a lot.
They get kicked a lot.
Um,
had head trauma is a on the job injury,
but you're not allowed to treat.
And on the job
injury with something that works like
human growth hormone,
like you'll talk to mark Gordon,
he'll tell you one of the best things
they can do to treat these concussions
and traumatic brain injuries is to
supplement with human growth hormone.
So you can't treat those injuries.
You can get them.
And if you're a normal everyday person
you can be treated,
but you can't be treated if you are a
fighter or if you're an athlete,
you know.
And if there's a thing with fighters as
well,
now they're not allowing them to use ivs
to rehydrate.
And the reason why is because ivs and
use of ivs can mask some of the signs of
steroids,
so something that was ultimately very
beneficial.
Now you can't use because people can use
it to cheat.
So even though it's just to rehydrate
you and even if they can prove that it's
just rehydrating you,
they can,
you can't use it because it could be
something that you're doing because
you're actually probably healthier for
the fighter like a day before to have
all those electrolytes in them and
everything.
And I'm right.
I mean rather than fight completed as
soon as you're cutting weight.
Yeah,
that's the argument.
But there's some arguments.
Some people,
I don't know if it's,
I haven't researched it,
but there's some people that say that
it's actually more effective to
rehydrate orally.
I've heard that's bullshit.
I've heard that's true.
I don't know what's right.
I'd have to talk to an expert about
that.
So do a google lead hard.
It's hard to be a,
it's hard to be way on top of all that
though.
Like when you're,
um,
these,
these fighters,
they travel,
you know,
in power lifting.
We do the same thing,
we use ivy bags,
so to rehydrate and guys we'll do 30
pound weight cuts and stuff like that.
So you do 30 pound weight cuts so that
you competed a lower level to power
lift.
Yeah,
lighter weight classes.
You're not getting hit in the head
though,
the right.
The rehydration orally.
If it's not effective as if you.
If you fight in a dehydrated state and
you get rattled,
your brain bleeds.
Right.
I say that almost all the deaths and pro
boxing,
almost all of them were in the lighter
weight divisions.
Wow.
Even though the heavyweights hit
hardest,
they didn't cut weight so they didn't
have all that same problem.
Is there any rules in UFC about cutting
weight?
How much percentage cut there should be?
If you can make the way you can fight,
you just have to make the weight.
Four o'clock on Friday and then
Saturday,
you know whenever your fight is the
fight,
don't start till four.
Do you think this thing will change the
game?
I hope it does.
I also think the UFC probably is going
to have to add more weight classes
eventually because there's not enough
way classes.
There's some big gaps between like one
85 and two.
Oh five.
That's 20 pound weight class.
That's a giant gap.
No,
I think that for fighters that are like
tweeners,
you know,
there's guys that are like a little bit
too big for this way,
but a little bit too small for that
weight.
They could use a one 95.
I think every 10 pounds we've saved like
be an advantage to actual,
you know,
to the fans and need to be more,
more champions,
more championship fights,
more money and then also the,
there could be some reasonable like a
champion versus champion.
Like one 95 versus two.
Oh,
five was pretty reasonable.
Whereas like one 85 versus two.
Oh five.
Like massive,
big fucking jump for those guys.
I think to answer your question about
steroids in the UFC,
I think we have to kind of define.
I think the real problem is what we said
earlier that the word steroid is it,
it's like
did it's a dirty word,
but if it's far as like supplements are
supplements be legal Kinda.
Everybody says supplements,
illegal.
Fuck.
We have muscle farm that sponsors the
UFC.
They sell a ton of Shit and supposed to
help you recover.
And protein powders.
All this jazz.
Think about creatine.
Absolutely.
Clinically proven to enhance
performance.
There's a lot of stuff that you can get
that's legal.
Even caffeine.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's all stuff that gives you like a
very slight bump.
I'm very slight edge and then taken all
together synergistically.
Like we'll supplement like says your
diet.
So if you have a,
you know,
a diet where you're not getting enough
stuff in it.
Like I was just reading this,
I posted something on facebook the other
day and people went crazy because I
posted this thing about fish oil and the
effect that it's officially not being
really scientifically proven.
You know,
it's like if you eat fish twice a week,
then you don't need it.
You know,
and everybody goes crazy.
No,
I need it.
And people,
people are convinced the supplement
industry is a $20 million up fish oil.
I'm convinced to that I need to have 20
pills a day.
It's a $24,
billion dollar industry and people are
convinced that they need these things.
You know,
there's some science behind fish oil and
Krill oil though.
Especially the anti inflammatory
process.
The inflammatory at a.
At a high dose.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's what I do.
I take a lot official.
It makes sense for that for if you're
trying to prevent heart disease and all
these things like that.
They're saying that,
you know,
there's really.
The link isn't there and if you eat
fatty fish you'll probably get enough in
your diet.
Really good fish like salmon that's high
in those healthy fats.
They're actually.
Yeah.
Everybody should eat that like once or
twice a week for Sushi.
Yeah.
I mean I believe I,
you know,
I'll read,
I'll read all this shit about
supplements,
right?
All this stuff.
I'll read like okay this doesn't work at
this barely works and whatever.
And the next thing I do,
I go open up my cabinet and I take 20
pills because like,
because it doesn't fucking work,
I don't know.
I mean it's like that placebo effect is
really,
really strong and you know,
certain things I take because I.
Oh,
I heard this works for,
you know,
Alpha lipoic acid when you eat carbs
that will help shuttle it in your
muscles.
Will do.
I know that that even works like,
I don't know,
Philip Polk assets supposed to be
clinically proven,
isn't it?
I think there's studies on Alpha lipoic
acid studies on everything.
Then you get into like the whole thing,
it's,
oh,
it's an antioxidant.
And you're like,
well,
wait a second.
What the fuck's an antioxidant?
What do I need?
Why do I need it?
You know,
like you,
you forget even why you needed to have
certain berries.
They're like the best antioxidant and
birds and birds.
And then they find out there's studies
that say that eating antioxidants in
your diet doesn't really matter.
It doesn't translate into antioxidants
in the bloodstream and all this stuff
like that.
So you gotta look at it like they say
you need certain precursors to be able
to digest these things.
So ice cream too fucking complicated.
You need to be your own doctor and I
need to do your own research.
I find I get big benefits when I eat a
lot of vegetables.
I feel a big benefit when I drink like
these Kale shakes the cow.
No,
I thought you were a tough guy.
It's healthy now.
He just makes fun of cattle.
The time I was making fun of
one of my friends because he's like,
he's like,
I went over here and I had a Kale Salad
is super skinny.
I'm like,
dude,
a Kale Salad.
Come on,
just make up a lie.
Say That you had a fucking 20 ounce
ribeye.
Well you could have both.
I just think in general that's way to
go.
Like you know,
we need,
we need vitamins and vitamins and
minerals and we need all these things in
our diet.
And so vegetables are probably the most
abundant source of great nutrients in
vegetables and fruits and things like
that.
So like,
why wouldn't you eat them like it seems
like it's,
I feel different when I eat them when I
have one of those Kale shakes with giant
clumps of fucking ginger in it and four
cloves of garlic and an apple and
celery.
It's amazing.
Cucumber could feel like fucking
superman.
You got to choke it down,
tastes like shit.
But when you choking it down once,
once you get it in,
you're like,
whoo,
you feel like you kinda like a double
shot of espresso,
but you don't,
you don't feel like jittery.
He just feel like crap.
I remember talking to you about.
Um,
uh,
it was kind of amazing and it was kind
of a good example for me talking to you
about like you were talking about going
on the road and traveling and you said,
Oh man,
I need to find a whole foods.
I don't eat that process shit.
And like to me that was like a real
eyeopener to find that.
Like somebody as busy as yourself goes
out of their way to find like good
healthy food and yeah.
And it's probably more important almost
for him because he's on a plane or in a
car or some shit all the time.
It's just you can only go so many.
I always bring a vitamin packs of those
pure athlete packs I bring with me to
supplement when I'm on the road,
I always make sure you get a lot of
salads.
Like I get salads before every meal,
whatever I'm eating.
I eat salads first.
But it's hard.
It's hard to find,
you know,
food that's not just full of garbage and
contaminated.
It is.
Yeah.
I mean like you go to subway,
I mean,
yeah,
you get bread and there's an there and
you kind of can fill you up.
But like,
you know,
all the different preservatives and
nonsense and process bullshit.
Fucking kills your stomach.
All the gluten.
Oh,
it's Chris's girlfriend eats tons of
vegetables and Cece,
she's a super hot.
So maybe that's the formula.
Yeah,
we can all be super hot chicks if Bruce
Jenner had only known about the Kale
Salad,
the um,
but the key,
the key,
like you said,
is good nutrition,
good solid things in your diet.
I think when you're dealing with things
like UFC fighters,
you're dealing with a level of
performance that they're requiring of
their body.
That's so extreme because even boxers
like the average boxer,
they do their boxing workout.
They'll spar a couple of times a week
depending upon the philosophy of the
camp.
In the morning.
They usually run like maybe they'll have
a strength and conditioning session
instead of a run,
but they're doing two workouts a day and
one of them is pretty mild.
It's not that big a deal,
so they're,
you know,
they can get through six to eight week
camp and most likely they never pull out
of fights.
It's very rare that a championship
fight,
manny Pacquiao almost pulled out a floyd
mayweather fight because he apparently
tours from,
but he wound up fighting.
Now there's a lawsuit because we pushed
through the injury.
Jesus,
you hear about all that.
Different people are suing them because
they bet a lot of money on them.
They didn't know that his right shoulder
fucked up and he had surgery right after
the fight,
but for the UFC fucking 20 percent of
the fights fall apart at least.
And guys fight injured all the time.
Even conor mcgregor when he fought
against Chad Mendez after,
although pulled out a fight,
mcgregor been getting stem cell shots in
his knee.
He was fucked.
Jason,
he was thinking he couldn't,
he didn't wrestle the entire camp
because he was thinking there's no way
because like I can't,
it'll fall apart.
Was a good fight.
Grateful that was good.
It's to be the toughest sport.
I mean,
I'd say that thing,
so people go like,
oh,
basketball players are the best athletes
or these guys are the best athletes.
I just think that,
uh,
the amount of maybe genetically
basketball,
you know,
but the amount of effort it takes to
step into the octagon,
the amount of mental focus,
it's like,
to me that's amazing.
It's like family.
I agree by it.
Basketball I think has the best six foot
six athletes.
Yeah.
Well fighting is not made up.
It's something that is part of us.
Everything else is made up.
Football,
basketball,
baseball,
made up,
sports.
You know,
when it came along we were like,
this is the only sport.
To me that makes sense.
It really makes sense.
It's like,
but the movements and the art are all
made up.
Had to figure out what's the most
effective way of striking and I don't
want to fuck someone up the fastest.
All of that is where the sport lies,
but I think you're right about the level
of athlete when you see the guys that
played for the NFL.
I mean those are fucking super freak
motherfuckers.
Will you come in in the UFC soon?
I'm sure.
Well,
if the money becomes right,
that's Jon Jones.
Jon Jones could have probably opted to
go and play in the NFL.
One hundred percent.
His brothers both do.
He could have.
What's crazy is he's not even the
toughest one in his family.
Both his brothers said they kick his
ass.
His younger brother and his older
brother.
That's crazy fucked up family is that
one of the guys got drafted.
One of his brothers got drafted.
I saw him a thermal jumping on each
other and shit.
They're all kicking the shit out of each
other.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
a lot of shit.
Must've got broken in the house.
Oh yeah.
I think that's why it happened and
that's why he came out so bad ass and
not afraid of anything about genetics.
I mean like that family,
the manning family,
like because these families are just
incredible.
Yeah.
Genetics and that goes a long way.
Oh,
100 percent.
Everything we're talking about,
you know,
Matt Hughes,
a former UFC welterweight champion,
his brother,
his twin,
it looks exactly like them their entire
lives.
They beat the fuck out of each other.
So of course he gets to the UFC with his
fucking steely eyed gaze.
He's used to facing himself literally
like a mirror version of him beating the
fuck out of him his whole life.
Just smashing each other,
running through walls,
like juggernaut summit,
sparring partner.
That's what I used to pick people up and
slam them.
Yeah,
there's a.
his brother's bigger.
Wow.
His brothers to 65,
Jesus Christ,
his brothers talking all kinds of shit
that he would,
uh,
he would kick his brother's ass.
I think Jon Jones could probably get up
to that way.
Right?
I mean,
he's probably fighting this whole life,
so we'll.
Chandler I think is a bigger guy,
but he's just an inch tall.
Two brothers in the NFL,
right?
Yeah.
Arthur to his brother,
arthur is even bigger than chandler.
His brother Arthur is more than 300
pounds.
Man,
that's a super athlete family.
His Dad's a patient due to his dad is
just naturally did very gifted.
It's,
it's taken a long time for the sport to
evolve to where it is.
Um,
you know,
like I'm,
I'm interested to see what will happen
with the female division.
You know,
like Rhonda is just killing everybody
and she's obviously amazing,
but I don't think the girls have caught
up to where the guys are at.
No,
not yet.
But have you seen a yawning and jet
check?
The strawweight champion?
Do you think Ronda is impressive?
This bitches,
ruth,
she's from Poland 1:15,
six time world Moy Thai champion.
The way we did it,
that was a fight companion one,
right?
We watched that girl get busted up.
Jessica Pinay.
Oh my God.
Do you use the ugliest female fight I've
ever seen in my life?
This girl's nose was smashed.
A giant gash across her nose and this is
Yolana chick from Poland was just
beating the fuck out of her.
I was literally to the point where
you're watching it like saying,
please stop this fight.
This fight is a terrible mismatch like
that.
That chick is lethal cause like when
Rhonda beats chicks up like she knocked
out batch with one punch and most of the
time she flips chicks on their back and
arm bars.
I'm in the first round.
This bitch beats the fuck out of checks
for like four rounds.
That's got to be cool.
Call that stuff because I saw your
excitement and it was like so genuine.
You know,
you're so pumped to call that fight.
Ronda fight.
Oh yeah.
It was a.
You know those.
You could feel it though when you watch
it.
It was a piece of history.
I felt.
It felt like a.
I feel like where she's at right now,
it's just so strange and rare.
It's like,
it's not just calling a fight.
It's like I feel like I'm calling a
piece of human history in modern day.
Mike Tyson.
She,
yeah.
She's like a real Charlie's angels
character.
Like there's never been like a hot chick
that actually can fuck up a lot of
dudes.
So it has been faking a movie.
Okay.
There's wonder woman changing,
you know,
it's like fake.
Someone was pounding on your door.
They'd like 2:00
in the morning like what the fuck?
And you open up the door and it was
Ronda rousey angry.
You'd be like,
Oh shit,
your heart would drop you like,
this bitch is going to beat my ass right
now to get my sleep or something.
She was outside.
She could,
you know,
break in your house.
You could kick your ass.
Like that's real.
And her confidence is through the roof.
That's just saw something today where
she's like,
can you beat floyd mayweather in a fight
or whatever?
And she's like,
yeah,
and I know rules fight.
I could beat anybody.
Well,
she said,
I'm not in a boxing match.
He's like,
he's a boxer.
I'm sure he would beat me in a boxing
match.
She goes,
but I don't have matches.
I have fights.
Right.
You know,
she's just letting them know.
She would ask.
She got ahold of him.
He's going flying,
that's for sure.
There's no way he's going to be able to
understand what she's doing.
If he tied up with her,
he really,
he,
he'd have so much to think about it.
I'm sure she trained with guys all the
time.
I've seen her but been there in the gym
with her flipping guys and I've seen her
tap guys.
I've seen it with my own eyes.
Tap good guys.
Get them an arm bars.
There's a video of her with a and trying
and try.
It was a video with her with Luke
rockhold and you know Luke,
let's or get into a position,
but she finishes them.
You know Luke rockhold fucking giant is
big fights at one 85 cuts,
a lot of weight to get down there.
Something.
He's strong.
He's a stud and she finished him with an
arm bar.
I'm like,
Whoa,
it's not even embarrassing.
She's the fucking best.
She's pretty Goddamn with it.
But was like,
what about steroids and that division
with the issue that I talk about Cyborg.
You got guys like,
I know you talk about it a lot in your
podcasts.
You get into um,
steroids here and there and um,
you know,
a lot of guys don't eat.
They don't even look like they're doing
it like Gilbert Melendez or hoists
Gracie,
you know,
it's like you can't tell anymore.
Well,
voice actually did look like he was
doing it when he got popped.
When you got pop.
We were there for that fight and I was
there with my friend Eddie,
Eddie Bravo,
and that he was like,
dude,
when is the last time you saw hoists
with traps traps?
Like he was pretty jacked and is way
heavier than normal.
He was like,
he usually is around one 70 something.
He was well over 200 pounds.
But I think because of the benefit of
steroids isn't just with weightlifting.
It's like overall,
you know,
overall recovery overall energy and
health,
taking a cocktail.
Probably a little growth hormone.
Little tests.
Little Epo.
Yes,
a hundred percent.
I think the a big thing too,
the vibrancy just having energy,
just having enthusiasm and they don't
test for Hipo do they?
Oh yes they do.
[inaudible] got popped for when he
fought against mighty mouse Johnson for
the flyway title and he's still
suspended because the others.
But there's guys,
because I know that test is pretty.
It's a,
it's a little wishy washy.
When we did bigger,
stronger,
faster,
we looked heavily into the HIPO test and
there's a guy that came up with a
definitive test,
a definitive like just either you're on
it or you're not a synthetically.
And um,
the,
he got a letter from the Olympic
Committee saying from the US Olympic you
soc saying we can't use your test
because we'll be out.
It's unfair.
Uh,
you know,
will be,
it will be unfair to the Americans
because the other foreign countries are
relying goosey tests.
Exactly.
That's hilarious.
So what they're saying is we're going to
have to allow a certain amount of
cheating to when exactly.
That's really what they're saying.
Well,
we have to be able to cheat just as much
as the rest of them.
If you look at the,
uh,
you don't want to do these testosterone
ratios,
like 99 point nine percent of human
beings should be at a one to one ratio.
Epi,
testosterone,
the testosterone and kind of thing.
And um,
they allow it to be like four to one or
six to six and now they'll have four.
Right?
So you can take a little bit and be
under the radar.
We've had guys pop it like 50 to one
back.
I remember when I was doing.
That's awesome.
They like gorillas don't want to see a
non tested UFC and have the guy's way,
like over 300 pounds.
They go one minute on and five minutes
off you go and just let him just kill
each other.
They just fucking slug it out.
I like the way you can't train.
That's the other thing you can't train
for fighting because that's an unfair
advantage to then you know,
how to fight and it ruins the fun.
Well,
the other person's training too,
so it's not an unfair advantage.
So you can lift weights.
That's about it.
That's it.
I think that uh,
there's,
there's a benefit to being a certain
weight,
but there's a negative effect when you
get over a certain weight.
And I think to 40 is around the right
weight.
I think a body weight,
well our body,
your,
how lean you are is probably a big,
a big thing too.
I think once you get under 10 percent,
I think is when you start to get in
trouble,
unless you're used to that,
unless your body's always under 10
percent,
then you could probably operate at that
body,
at that being that lien for awhile,
you know,
I just think if guys have good defensive
skills and they can avoid the bum rush
for the first couple rounds guy.
So like over to 40,
they have a real hard time getting into
the third,
fourth,
and fifth rounds.
It's just too much mass to carry around
two bones and the muscle and all the
blood's being that big.
Yeah,
the oxygen requirements.
So I think like a guy like Cain
Velasquez is always about to 40,
known for a spectacular cardio.
Fabrice overdo them,
same thing somewhere in the two
thirties.
That seems to be a shocking.
And it was crazy.
Came fucked up.
I mean Cain is known for his cardio,
so I think he just got a little cocky
and decided not to go to Mexico City,
but Mexico City is so I,
I can't believe how high it is.
7,000
plus feet above altitude or trouble
breathing.
I worked on the gym and a fucking
elliptical machine that was breathing
heavy and it's almost like you can't be.
These guys are gonna fight,
but for Breesa was real smart.
He moved to a place that's a thousand
feet above that for like a month and a
half.
And cain was only there for two weeks
and his improved all the ratio.
You know,
I,
I see a lot of time at Gold's gym.
He,
uh,
he's improved vastly,
you know,
every,
every step of the way,
which is nice to see too.
Well,
he was such a high level Jujitsu guy.
He was one of the best Jujitsu fighters
in the world.
And to get that good at Jujitsu you have
to have an intense mind for learning.
And so he just took that and applied it
to boxing and kickboxing and just once
he figured that out,
everybody was fucked because you don't
want to go to the ground without that
beat some awesome fighters.
Eco,
the first guy,
right?
He's the first guy to submit fader or
first got to submit cane,
you know,
that's,
that's a pretty God damn spectacular
resume.
All he has to do is beat a few more guys
and he is arguably one of the greatest
heavyweight,
if not the greatest of all time share.
It's interesting that you bring up those
two fighters.
It makes me Kinda think like maybe
there's a upper weight limit of muscle
mass that you can carry around because
like neither one of those guys is real
lean.
So maybe around the 200 pound mark is
probably almost like the cutoff if you
start being more jacked than that,
maybe you can't sustain it for three
rounds.
Yeah,
I think it's a matter of durability.
Like you want to be big enough so that
you could take shots but you can't be
too big because you just can't carry it
into those.
Especially a guy like Cain,
although Coleman and occur,
we're kind of the exception,
but they were.
They were on everything.
Bathtubs full of shit.
Brock Lesnar,
animal,
just an animal in such a freak of
nature.
I still maintain to this day that if
somebody got a hold of Brock lesnar
early on and said,
listen to me and you can be the best
heavyweight fighter ever like a for us
as a hobby or a matt hume,
like someone who's a real expert in mma
who barack listened to and just said,
look,
this we're going to do first.
The first thing we're going to do is
we're going to nothing but striking for
like a couple of years and you're not.
You're not going to get hit.
I don't want you to develop any bad
habits and you're not hitting anybody
either.
All you're gonna do is you're going to
do movement with people.
We're going to hit you.
Get to do pad work,
you're going to do technique work and
we're going to have that shit built into
your your neurons and we're gonna.
We're gonna,
have all these movements.
They're going to be a part of your
natural movement and if you're willing
to do that,
you're going to develop a base and that
base will translate into success,
but otherwise you're going to be scared
of getting hit and that's what his
problem always was.
He would always get tagged by like
someone like Shane car or more Alistair
overeem and you could see just he didn't
have enough time in there.
He doesn't like it either.
Yeah.
You got to spar with guys who barely
touch.
You were like,
they're not hurting you and you don't
hurt them,
and that's in the beginning.
That's like the most critical because
otherwise you're gonna,
miss giant chunks of the development
because you just get a fucking swearing
piece that he was able to get to where
he did during all those years of wwe
first.
Yeah,
like just fucking.
What if he just went on?
If we adjust,
like you said,
gone straight in.
Oh,
he would have been the best,
but he was still a heavyweight champion
of the fucking world.
Knocked out randy coture beat the shit
out of Frank Mir.
He's a stud.
I love watching him.
He just had to.
I was.
I was kind of bummed but happy when he
decided to quit mma recently had a.
He had a moment where it's was trying to
figure out whether it's going to keep
going the wwe or give one more shot at
the UFC and I know he talked to Dana,
he talked to the UFC.
He was really thinking about it,
but ultimately you don't want to see him
go down a bad path of like being the guy
that gets,
you know,
concussion is.
I think that was a big one who's worried
about posting concussion syndrome?
Like Joseph Valtellina use the glory
welterweight champion.
He just stepped down and relinquish his
title because of concussions,
like concussions in MMA or a big fucking
issue.
And you don't hear about it.
How do you feel about like,
I watch a lot of fights where,
you know,
we want to see him go on,
you just want to see your health.
Some guys will get,
don't stop it,
don't stop it.
I'm going to get pounded and come back.
And they come right back.
And it's like,
oh well,
good thing they didn't call it,
you know,
great job,
Herb Dean or whoever the ref is.
And then other times guys get pounded
and uh,
they get pounded 10 times in a row and
then they're out.
And then it's like,
well,
they didn't need the 10 shots to be out.
You know,
it's why the fight is actually
happening.
I always root for the guy to come back,
but after the fights over,
like if I'm analyzing it from a rational
standpoint,
I'm always like,
oh,
stop.
It is in trouble.
Yeah.
It's,
it's not good at your ring side.
I mean,
it must be a little scary at times when
people are blasted.
Right.
Some of the knockouts are,
there's been some knockouts.
We'd probably see the eyes and
everything.
Right.
Yeah.
How did you get into that?
Like where you were you fighting before
way before your wedding,
way before you had a really big interest
in it?
Yeah,
well I,
I,
um,
I had stopped competing in like 1988.
That's when I got into comedy and maybe
89 was probably like my last kickboxing
fights and then I went into standup and
then I just trained recreationally until
like around [inaudible] 93.
The UFC came around.
I think I saw the first,
a tape,
I saw a tape of it at 94 and then I was
like,
Holy Shit,
what does this Jujitsu style?
We were there from day one to it.
I watched that first paper view live.
I remember that like crazy to wanting to
get a chance.
I saw it on tape.
Someone talked about it at the gym and I
was like,
what is going on?
They you believe it,
it's like a dream come true for us.
So that was a commercial floor.
I'm like,
oh my God.
That was crazy.
Back in the day.
And remember it used to be in the faces
of death section of the videos are for
like a long time.
It went completely away.
Well that's when I came in.
I came in while I was banned.
I started working in [inaudible] 97.
So I started doing the post fight
interviews and 97 while I was a sitcom.
These radio,
I would go on the weekends,
fly off the fucking bum,
fuck,
Alabama is a great book of blood in the
cage that outlines all that stuff and it
outlines like how a Dane.
I got into it and they went to an event
and he was like,
this just sucks.
They don't even sell tee shirts.
They don't know what's going on.
We need to like take this over,
you know,
that kind of thing.
It's really cool.
Yeah.
They bought it in 2001 I think.
And uh,
I came in in 2002 and started doing the
commentary.
I remember it when it got in trouble
before the,
uh,
the ultimate fighter.
I actually worked for wwe and Vince
Mcmahon,
I remember being in limbo of Vince
Mcmahon being like,
dude,
it's like they're trying to sell it.
You should buy it.
And he's like,
he's,
I don't know.
And then two years later they tried to
unsuccessfully start some sort of a.
and I may think,
but I think Vince has been amended.
Uh,
yeah,
they,
they would try to,
they never,
never got off the ground.
They were planning on it.
Yeah.
What happened though was Vince and he
had a legitimate concern is like,
I don't want it,
don't take the legitimacy out of it.
You know,
like if he owned something like that,
you know,
they might think it's fixed.
I think it's fake.
Well,
they didn't think that about the XFL,
right?
Guess not.
Yeah.
I think the real problem is the talent
pool know there's not that many good
fighters in the UFC owns the contracts
for 500 fighters.
Wow.
And they're all the best fighters.
Sure.
We,
there's not one fighter in any weight
class outside of the UFC that you can
make a rational argument that's the best
fighter in that weight class.
So once they have that,
it's like,
boy,
it's hard to sell a league when you know
that the UFC,
this is our 170 pound world champion.
Like,
well,
is that really because everybody knows
Robbie lawler is the fucking world to
launch any sort of competition.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's hard for me.
You know,
I get it.
Well this in other organizations like a
world series of fighting us,
some good fights,
beltour have some good bytes,
but it's just gonna be real hard for
them to build stars to build like a.
because everybody,
like a kid coming up wants to be the
best,
you know,
if he wants to be the best one and 35
pounds,
he wants to fight Tj dillashaw.
He doesn't want to fight Marty fuck face
from a,
from a Mike's Hardcore fighting
championship.
You know what I mean?
It's like you just want to be the best,
so they're always going to recruit the
best guys.
They're ahead of the game,
you know,
that's not a lockdown game and you know,
especially like if like Bella tour
science or,
and maybe somebody gets Gina Carano like
chicken get weird.
I feel like it's all like the same with
wrestling now if you look at wwe,
they've been,
they've had a monopoly for awhile.
Then wcw came along and they started
getting popular,
but then you know,
now that the web,
the legs,
the other league TNA,
it's so lame,
you know,
it's like,
nobody really gives a fuck about it at
all and that's the thing is like in the
end like UFC will be,
it will be around forever.
It's like the NFL,
it,
unless they sell it,
they,
they could,
they could get to a point where they're
like,
look,
let's get the fuck out of here.
Yeah,
work killing us.
Because Dana works all day long every
day.
He's constantly flying all over the
world and Lorenzo's doing the same
thing.
It's like,
it's a lot of work.
It's not easy doing what those guys are
doing and when they're gone,
everybody's gonna miss him and people
complaining about the EOC,
but when they're gone you realize the
alternative and if they've created an
industry,
people are mad about a stupid uniforms.
I mean,
that's the last thing I'd get mad about
it.
Well,
they have some points fighter side when
it comes to that with the sponsorships.
It's just they lose too much money,
you know,
it's just.
I've been,
I was lucky enough to get in on the
last,
uh,
the last thing before a reebok took over
with,
uh,
with one of the fighters and was pretty
cool.
It's cool to see the logo up there and
all that stuff.
It was nice people.
Well that's a big part of what the
fighters get.
It's what you would say,
like ego sponsorships,
like dynamic fastener is on like so
many.
I don't even know what that is,
but it's on so many different tee
shirts.
So many that'll reebok said the there.
I guess it's,
it seems like I'm over the spread over
all the fighters.
They'll make more money.
The younger fighters or is that just not
true?
I don't think it's true.
Yeah.
No,
I don't think it's true.
I think maybe for deal changes or they
start to make more money and you know,
it becomes something bigger than what it
is right now.
But if you look at it right now,
Tim Kennedy said it best reasonably.
He said on one strikeforce card he made
more money in sponsorships.
Then the reebok paid out for the entire
last UFC car from Brazil.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Wow.
So all those people were wearing reebok
gear.
He made more money from one fight in
strikeforce.
Yeah.
So that's.
Yeah,
it looked like reebok had a pretty good
deal from what I heard.
I don't think it's a good deal.
No.
I mean,
I mean for Reebok,
but no,
I don't think it's ideal for Reebok
because what I'm saying because I think
it gives them a bad name in some ways.
Yeah.
I understand all these people come out
and whereas.
Yeah.
No,
no,
that's not true,
but all these people are complaining
like Tim Kennedy complaints,
titch Dorian complainants who gets fired
for are complaining lots of fighters,
a complainant,
Brendan sharp complaint or all these
different guys complained that that's
all negative press towards their brand.
I mean,
they're not a person right there a
brand.
If you associate that brand,
you can't like fire the head guy and
change the brand.
The brand is still the brand.
You know,
when everybody's gonna associate that
brand with it.
Is it a big name brand?
Yeah.
Good.
You see a big name brand attached to a
sport like the UFC?
Absolutely,
but I feel like whenever you're in a
situation where the fighters are going
to lose money,
that's always the number one concern
that people have.
Everybody knows the window of
opportunity for a fighter is extremely
small,
so you have a few years to make some
money,
right?
So when you take some of that money away
from them in terms in favor of prestige,
the prestige,
which is inarguable,
Reebok's,
a huge brand,
it's great to be in business with a big
brand,
but if it costs fighters money,
boy that's going to be hot.
You can't not see that.
It's not like we're going to put
blinders on and ignore that.
You have to address that.
Social media is a huge thing.
So the fighters are going to be heard.
The new just.
It's the big.
It's bigger than anything because if you
bitch about something on twitter and
someone says,
Holy Shit,
Chris Bell just went off about that and
then some newspaper gets ahold of it and
then boom,
it goes viral on facebook and people
repost it and tweet it because we live
in a different world.
And so anytime someone like stitch gets
fired because he said something about,
hey,
you know,
reebok of this deal kind of sucks for me
because now I'm not making as much
money.
So they fire them and then all of a
sudden,
boom,
that becomes a way bigger issue than it
was just with them saying that if he
just said that and that was it,
it would have been a small issue.
But him saying that and then getting
fired for it,
it compounds the issue.
People react quickly to social media,
you know,
makes everything go faster.
You know,
they start wearing Nike's history.
This is what.
I'm not a business person.
I'm not.
I would,
if I was running the UFC,
it would've been bankrupt a long fucking
time ago.
But you,
you,
I think it's,
it's real.
It's real dangerous.
Looking at the bright side of deals like
this,
like let's look at the bright side.
I'm,
let's look at the worst case scenario.
What's the worst case scenario?
Everybody is going to hate reebok.
That's the worst case scenario.
People gonna be mad at the UFC and mad
at Reebok.
So I go,
Ooh,
I don't know man.
I was able to sponsor a Joseph Benevidez
and that was pretty cool.
But you know what?
What is your company a slingshot?
This the slingshot that I had you throw
on earlier,
did banged out,
banged out some pushups in.
Yeah,
he's got this cool device that you.
A slide.
It's like this heavy duty rubber thing
that you slide up to your biceps and it
actually gives you a bit of an
assistance when doing pushups or bench
press or something like that.
Yeah,
it feels good,
man.
I like it.
Where can people get this?
We want to get how much you benched on
it?
How much you bench go?
There's the fucking plug.
How much you bench dot?
Yeah.
What do you bench some retarded number?
Like 700 pounds.
I'm five.
My best bench press and competition.
This is where the bench shirt,
which is much more heavy duty than than
something like the slingshot.
It's just a supportive device.
It's crazy looking.
Looks like a straight jacket,
but I did an 854 pound bench press in
the 275 pound weight class.
So then without a bench shirt,
my best bench press is 560 pounds in
competition.
That's like a Harley Davidson.
Right.
How much do those weigh?
Those weigh like 800 pounds.
That's crazy.
That's a lot of God.
Damn.
Wait Dude.
How long have been at it for a long
time.
I started when I was 12,
two older brothers that are dicks that
forced me to lift weights even though I
was and I didn't fucking want to know.
What are those bench shirts?
Those vests?
Yeah.
Bencher wearing a denim jacket.
Backwards is what it's like and
originally it was originally it was
designed just
to be protective and then people were
like,
wait a second.
Not only is it protective,
but I can lift more weight with it.
And so then they started making them
more and more extreme.
They used to be like one layer.
Then they started making two layers and
they started making them out of a pair
of fucking genes and they started making
them out of a canvas and all kinds of
different where people revolted against
that and now everybody lifts.
Ra are a lot of people lift robin,
you could say,
oh,
how much do you bench?
Oh,
fine.
And raw would just be with just race
ramps on.
What did you do?
Five.
Five slash 65 slash 60.
That's crazy.
You can do 300 pounds more than one of
those shirts.
Yeah.
Isn't that nuts?
That is on the slot to his squad was
like a thousand pounds to 180 squat.
And fell pretty bad with 185.
He fell.
I fucking felt.
Well,
what happened was,
is there's a girl that's a,
was trained under Jim and she's running,
she's running the squat rack.
The squat rack is called a monolift.
And uh,
when you,
uh,
you released this like lever so that I
don't have to walk the weight backwards,
you understand that,
right?
Another walked away backwards,
the lever moves out of the way and I
pick the weight up and go.
The problem is the girl's hot and she's
in a sundress and I'm trying to.
I'm trying to concentrate on a lift
here.
And so midway down on the squat,
one nice shoots out to left the other
new shoots out the other way.
And next thing I know is on the fucking
ground.
So it was it on your back or in front of
you and now I.
well luckily I got kind of unloaded from
the weight quickly it,
it fell back behind me and I fell
forward.
I was fucked up for months from that.
That was a,
that was a pretty bad.
How'd you fuck?
Like what kind of injury?
You know what?
I never went to the doctor.
I'm not a fan of going to the doctor so
I just a rub some dirt on it and just
lived with pain for awhile.
It was like black and blue.
My ankle was fucked up.
My knees were fucked up.
But you know,
I,
I did go to a,
I went to a friend of mine.
He's like,
what are they?
Gonna compare x rays and Mris and stuff
too.
It's like you already know you're all
fucked up anyway.
Oh,
you fucked up from lifting?
No,
I'm not that bad.
I'm,
I'm pretty much.
Okay.
I have why General Mri revealed damage?
Well he just,
he was just saying like,
your knees are probably.
There's probably slight tears here and
there,
you know,
because I've had knee pain and all kinds
of different things for years,
so he was just saying like,
you're,
they're going to tell you that you're
fucked up.
He's like,
what are you gonna do about it?
Well,
shoulders are a big one for guys.
Events that much.
Right.
The shoulders packs and people blow off
their pack.
That's how I invented the slingshot was
I tore my peck three times.
I injured my times.
Yeah.
They were all stitched back in.
No,
no he didn't.
I don't like going to the doctor.
So you tore it and just dealt with it.
Just dealt with it.
Yeah.
I didn't.
I never had.
I never had like a rupture,
you know?
I never tore it all the way through.
I never toured all the way through to
where it was like bleeding down to the
bicep and all that nasty shit that can
happen with a torn Pec.
I do it my tricep and it's brutal.
Yeah.
I've seen both the bone,
seeing a lot of people that get the
bicep curls up like a golf ball.
It looks crazy,
you know,
like,
uh,
there's some fighters that,
that like getting punched in the face.
I kind of like pain.
So for me it's kind of a,
it's kind of just part of the territory
with training.
Yeah,
the pain guys.
Those are weird people.
Person I know.
I'm weird.
Yeah,
I don't mind it.
I don't mind.
Well,
the thing about soreness,
it's like it lets you know,
like,
yeah,
I fucking really got to work out.
There's a difference between soreness
though and not being able to get up out
of bed in the morning and stuff like
that.
That stuff's brutal.
Joint pain,
especially pain and joint pain are two
different animals.
Joint pains.
Rough.
Yeah.
Can you know,
you get some little shit that for some
reason you just can't handle it.
It's like the little tiny things that
just no way.
You're like,
mother Fucker,
why my elbow hurts so bad.
Goddamn hangnails.
What's the littlest thing from crazy
lifting in general,
like every,
you know,
pretty much everybody we know has some
sort of injury hurt somewhere where
you're not working out hard.
One or two things and people.
People,
I looked at a certain forms of exercise
like crossfit,
saying like,
oh,
everybody gets hurt,
and I'm like,
everybody gets hurt.
Power lifting,
everybody I know that's a bodybuilder
gets hurt like everybody else.
Take any of them extremely doing this.
And that's what we talked about.
We were talking about on the way up here
is a slowing down in your workouts.
Just taken time to actually,
uh,
think about what you're dealing with.
One thousand pounds and 1000.
Oh yeah,
this five actually make this one.
But see the sun drop.
Why does it say tumble?
Tumble?
There we go.
That's the girl in the sun dress.
She fucked you up.
We're going to look how big his face.
Yeah.
I'm about 320 pounds in this video or
300 pounds for.
Damn,
dude,
that's a wide ass stance to you.
Always squad that wide.
Uh,
in a squatsuit I squatted a little bit
wider.
It creates some tightness around the
hips and kind of gives you some support
through your hips because pretty hot to
the guy behind.
Isn't that I'm the trainer.
UFC.
Oh yeah,
that's a novella.
Who is a trainer of some UFC fighters,
Chad Mendez,
and I'm a Joseph Benevidez and a bunch
of other small dudes that can fuck
people up.
Yeah.
It's funny that they have a whole camp
full of those dudes,
isn't it?
This is this you've given out.
Oh Jesus.
Dude.
God Damn.
That's a lot of weight.
Yeah.
And so like,
uh,
when it happened and I felt it,
it wasn't,
it didn't hurt that bad initially,
but then as time wore on it got worse
and worse and worse.
The swelling to start getting fucking
crazy.
I stayed at the competition and I'm a
coach for all the athletes that are in
that video basically.
And I stayed the whole time and helped
everybody and just like I normally would
normally do.
And then the next day when I woke up,
I just,
I couldn't,
by the time I got home even I couldn't
even,
I couldn't even get upstairs to go to
bed.
I just fucking sat on the couch and sat
on the chair and just slept in the chair
for the night and slept right there for
the next two or three days.
You know,
one of the interesting aspects of your
film was Louie Simmons,
amazing.
Greg,
I have one of his,
a reverse hypers and the back things are
awesome.
Credible machine for,
for decompressing your lower back and
pumping blood into it and everything.
Oh,
things amazing.
But he's a refreshing character to,
you know,
it was funny when you were saying that
you were going to get off steroids.
He's like,
we'll do that.
Yeah,
of course.
But that's,
that's the attitude that all those guys
have.
It's like,
look,
you just have to accept the fact that
you are now a steroid dude.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
And you know,
making a good documentary.
I think it's a lot about casting.
It's about them.
You pick,
you know,
it's just like any other movie who you
picked to be in the movie.
And Louie Simmons was somebody that
inspired me to do things differently to
think differently.
Used chains and bands.
I used to go into Gold's gym,
you know,
15,
20 minute pioneer that by the way,
bands and chains and all that type of
change on the bar to accommodate
assistant.
So like the band will.
Oh,
you can tell him it's getting harder as
you get higher,
as you squat is called good.
It's called accommodating resistance.
It basically makes you a drive into the
bar faster.
So if you can picture a bunch of chains
on the bar,
there's um,
let's say 40 pounds of chains on the
bar.
As you lower those weights will be less
and less weight on the bar and as you go
to pick it back up,
it will be more and more weight on the
bar scene.
You have to actually physically move
faster.
I'm a way that I try to explain it to
people as if you were to try to hop up
on this podcast table.
You can't do it slowly.
So we trained with bands and change a
similar thing.
You have to do it quickly,
you have to try to get a lot of
acceleration into it.
Does that make sense?
So that would probably eight and
explosive shit like football or punching
people.
And then also the also a huge benefit of
it is that the weight is lighter at the
bottom.
Same thing kind of happens with the
slingshot,
but with the weight being lighter at the
bottom,
it's,
uh,
creates a safer environment because the
bottom of a squat and the bottom of
bench presser kind of somewhat dangerous
positions to be in.
How much does it chain way normally they
usually wait about 20 pounds.
The ones that we use pretty pretty God
damn thick.
Yeah.
Like big ass chains in the seventies
boating type of.
The thing is I would read a magazine
called power lifting USA.
We didn't have the.
Oh I thought you were going to say
inches inches.
I'll tell talking about that.
And so action.
So we used to look at that,
that magazine,
I was the only,
only information on strength training
and the entire world that a kid,
15 years old growing up in Poughkeepsie,
New York and get his hands on.
So I would read that and I'd go to the
gym.
I try out all these weird things and
people like,
what the fuck are you doing?
And um,
when I was a kid I was swatting you'll
500,
four sets of eight reps and people are
like,
what,
what does he squatted?
Six hundred and 75 pounds in high
school.
He was just fucking,
what the fuck are you won?
Right?
And I'm like,
I'm not,
I'm not on anything.
I'm on Louie Simmons,
you know.
And so when I started training a mark to
just be,
you know,
an animal,
uh,
it was,
he had a lifting belt that said Roy
suck.
I wrote out a director of bigger,
stronger,
faster ladies and gentlemen,
and it said,
Roy suck.
And I would go to the gym and all these
guys were like all juiced up like
Poughkeepsie,
New York.
It's like,
I don't know what is in the water there,
but everybody was on something.
And um,
and I just always wanted to sort of deny
that,
go against that.
Like I'm not doing this.
And um,
that's why that was the whole,
the whole genesis for that movie was the
fact that I always had this weird moral
thing,
you know,
like against it,
I got,
I can't do that.
That's just fucking cheating.
Jamie,
can you get some of those?
Caveman given us those nitro cans.
Those fuckers are good.
Bring in a few of those kind of kills.
No,
this is the good shit man.
We're out a regular coffee.
What,
what was it that pushed you over the
edge of,
made you want to try steroids then?
How Old Society?
No.
I went to USC and there's hot chicks
everywhere and I wasn't a gorilla.
You fucking squatting $600.
Wasn't really in good shape.
I didn't look good,
but all you have to do is clean up your
diet.
He's always had to kind of a conflict
with a with is like build.
He's always been trying to get in better
shape.
And so I think that uh,
steroids is a,
a quicker and easier route in some cases
to a get a little bit better shape and I
totally understand that.
But I mean,
you were,
it sounds like if you.
Would you say you squat six 75 percent?
Yeah,
when I was younger.
Yeah.
Fucking wait.
I mean,
you have to be a big fucker to do that.
That was about,
I was a little bit fatter than I am now
to great out way about to 10.
I was about to 40 maybe,
you know,
so it was just a matter of you just
didn't like the way you looked at.
I didn't like the way it looks is
important.
Everybody else was in good shape.
I was training at golds.
Venice had been goal.
I've been gold's gym in Venice,
in the hoaxster would be in there and
you know,
macho man,
Randy Savage and I'm going to do when a
black guy daughter the hawks.
Jim,
that's depressing.
Shit,
wasn't it?
As it means he'll,
he'll be back on his word rent.
He said some bad things,
you know,
he'll be,
I think with wrestling,
like it's the most inexcusable things
have been excused and I think that
they'll figure out a way to.
Did they fire him from the wwe?
They erased them from their website
completely.
Like,
as if he never existed.
Uh,
you can't do that to the Hawks stadium.
Yeah.
I mean it's still pending the iron
sheik.
Yeah,
I was there.
I saw it.
That'd be amazing.
If you were there physically?
No,
I've never been one of those things.
Madison Square Garden.
I didn't.
The wrestling,
I don't know.
No,
no,
because we were just saying all that
shit.
We were in.
You were into martial arts since you
were a little kid too,
so I was going to do it in high school.
In high school.
I love Jimmy superfly snowfall and Bob
backlund and all that wrestled Jimmy in.
Did you listen to where your career goes
in wrestling?
He pinned Jimmy superfly snuck a at an
Indian casino for like 50 bucks in front
of about 40 people.
That's awesome.
Where was this time in my life.
What part?
I don't know.
Where the fuck I was.
Where was I?
Somewhere in California.
Somewhere High Dam bucks.
50 bucks.
Yep.
God Damn it.
What did he.
He looked like a transvestite.
He was hot.
Wow.
Rowdy Roddy Piper just passed away.
Yeah,
he was the nemesis.
I'm having a next week,
next Monday at the comedy store.
There's a a tribute.
Rowdy Roddy Piper and all the people at
the new one.
We're going to come in and I never got a
chance to meet.
That guy always bummed me out because he
was fucking,
her was awesome.
That's all I heard.
I heard was such
a great guy.
That's what we loved about wrestling.
Like we just love the personalities.
We loved it.
If UFC was around,
we were like little kids.
We probably went into that route,
you know,
our older brother was always beating
somebody up,
you know,
and that's,
he,
he went into pro wrestling because
that's all existed at the time.
But I know if mma existence at the time
you would have went that way.
The um,
the thing when you did with Jimmy snuck
up,
like how old was he at the time?
He's got to be in a 65.
This was probably about 15 years ago.
A sixties then.
But yeah.
Yeah,
he was definitely a definitely old.
Definitely had a shape.
Yeah,
it wasn't,
it wasn't pretty.
Was it weird?
Did it feel weird?
I was fucking really weird.
Yeah.
And the poor guy,
like what does he do for the wrestling
in general is weird.
Like wrestling another dude.
And like tights and stuff,
it's really strange.
I mean,
like we,
we used to run this small wrestling
federation with a guy named Rick Bass
man who's a good friend of ours and um,
it was called upw ultimate pro wrestling
and we put like 30 guys into wwe.
So a lot of times like these young guys
had to work with the older guys like
John Ciena.
We'd be working with,
uh,
Greg,
the hammer,
Valentine to hammer Valentine.
Like,
Hey kid,
I'm not going to bump for anyone,
you know,
bump means hit them.
I'm never gonna hit the mat,
you just to beat the shit out of here.
So it was like,
that's part of a part of that.
What does that mean?
Bump?
What did he just hit?
The Mat basically,
uh,
you know,
just like fall for the other guy.
Meaning meaning like,
the older guys don't want to do any of
the work.
You're going to work around them and
make them look good,
but they're not actually going to do
anything.
Oh.
So they don't fall down anymore because
they're all being.
Well that makes sense.
Like fuck you on my phone now.
It's super fly.
Have that kind of a conversation with a
little bit.
Yeah.
What is,
how does it,
what does it go down?
Well he basically uh,
he just told me to different moves he
wanted to do and I was like,
all right,
we'll just sounded like I'm not really
getting into many moves.
Was what happened was he did the
superfly move,
right?
Yeah.
And then you flipped them over and
pinned them.
So you ended up winning.
Right.
He still does the superfly change.
It's amazing.
He wanted me to like sit way up though,
you know,
I like to catch him and I did and it
fucking,
it hurt like a motherfucker.
I'm sure know these old guys will steph,
you,
you ever have another man jump off the
top rope on,
you know,
I have not.
Do you ever see the one with Brock
Lesnar does the shooting star head?
Yeah,
I was actually there,
done that move like hundreds of times
when he was,
when he was younger and the different
federations where he got the web.
I weren't really sucked.
I worked at that Wrestlemania mania that
was up in the sky box.
I'm watching.
I'm like,
oh my God,
he's dead.
He's dead.
Meanwhile,
he's still completes the pin.
Yeah.
He just got his fucking paying for a
week or something.
He was.
He was messed up a little bit,
but he wasn't that bad compared to what
it should have been.
He's such a freak.
He really is one of the biggest fleets
in an interview.
Like there's like two years and he just
doesn't remember drugs because the
drugs.
Oh wait,
what was the on?
I'm not sure if others.
Probably Oxycontin.
They do.
That was the other thing that was in
this in mind.
There was an article about Rowdy Roddy.
Piper were talking about the the drugs
that they do.
Here it is right here.
Oh Shit.
Look at this.
Oh my God,
Dude.
A normal person would be dead and he's
to 90 wrestled in Seattle.
Kind of check.
The is a.
yeah,
he was giant.
Will what?
We're just talking to talking about
Piper to interview.
Oh,
they were talking about the amount of
time that they spend on the road
wrestling and that like any other sport
you get like time break.
Like these guys are restaurant.
There's 100 nights a year,
which is crazy.
Like you don't,
you can't recover,
you just can't recover.
So they all get hooked on pain pills.
I just did a movie called the
resurrection of Jake,
the snake.
It's about jake the snake Roberts who
was an eighties wrestler,
you know,
and he was a crack addict,
so to another wrestler.
Diamond Dallas page helps him get sober
and we just showed that movie at slam
dance.
He'll be out pretty soon,
but it really shows what these guys go
through.
Um,
you know,
afterwards it shows it's a documentary
that's just like the movie,
the wrestler.
It's a real,
real life.
Darker.
Darker though.
Yeah,
pretty much.
It's fucking dark.
Jake,
the snake is a dallas diamond page is
doing wrestling or doing yoga now yoga,
but yoga,
he's fucking crazy fit for an old dude,
a superman.
Pushups,
you know,
on his fingertips.
Push that takes his ankle and puts it up
by his fucking face and she went.
I went to his house when we were doing
the documentary.
I was an executive producer on a
documentary,
which I do all the Hollywood stuff.
I help get it sold to help get it to
festivals,
all that kind of stuff and I just really
believed in it and I believed in it from
the beginning.
I knew they were making it and they
asked me to get behind it really early,
so when I went down to their house to
work on the movie,
he's like,
I'm going to take you through this yoga
thing.
And I'm like,
okay,
what is this bullshit?
Within 10 minutes he had a heart rate
monitor.
My heart rate was up to 1:55
and he's like,
okay,
we got to slow you down to keep you at
like 1:45.
So this is like this constant cardio
flexing,
moving,
awesome yoga thing that somebody like me
needs for mobility.
I think it's really,
it's actually a really cool thing that
he's doing well.
Yoga is great for mobility.
It's really hard to do.
It's one of those things where you look
at a bunch of fucking soccer moms,
but then you get in there,
you're like,
Holy Shit,
this is a little bit more digestible for
someone like me because it's a lot
based.
He sorta basis it around wrestling,
flex like this and hold it and it's kind
of fun,
you know?
Yeah.
I get it.
It's kind of,
there's no,
no mosque days.
Now you had a double hip replacement.
Yeah.
Rick actually rate towards the end of
doing bigger,
stronger,
faster.
Uh,
when we were doing the movie,
I was just worn down all the time.
I'm like,
I don't know what's going on.
I can barely walk.
I had just kept having all these
problems with my hips and um,
went and got it checked out and the
doctor said,
okay,
walk across the room.
I walked across the room.
He said,
you need to fake ed two new hips.
And I'm like,
what?
Like,
what are you talking about?
He's like,
you need to new heads.
A doctor that itselves hips.
He was an orthopedic surgeon,
you know?
And when the,
what did the MRI reveal?
I'm sure they did bone on bone and my
bone was completely smashed on both
sides.
So they were smashed into the,
into your engineer.
He was in a lot of pain all the time.
You could only,
I mean like three,
four hours at a time was what you could
give to the film.
Usually in a new.
We're just shy.
Sit down a lot and get out of this.
You said this is a genetic issue?
Yeah,
my dad has the same thing.
My Dad has two fake hips now,
but he didn't get him until way later.
So what happened was they,
you know,
who knows if,
if a wearing down of the hips squatting
all that much and whatever.
I don't really blame it on power lifting
because I don't think that that's really
the cause because there's a million
power lifters out there and I'm the one
with two fake hips,
you know.
So it's not like,
oh this happens.
Every power lifter,
you know,
it doesn't mean you think it has mess,
have some effect.
I think everything has.
Everything has an effect.
You know,
it's like they played football,
you wrestled like that.
I mean he's,
he's,
uh,
he doesn't have to fake hips and he's
the same genetics,
you know,
as you know,
as me.
So I,
I got it from my dad,
you know,
my dad has the same but what do they,
what do they classify it as?
What are they classified as?
Just osteoarthritis and it's just so.
But you only get into your hips now.
I have it in my ankles and my knees.
I had both.
My knees need to be replaced,
but I'm just sort of,
Jesus,
I just sorta like putting that off
because like you said,
we have new therapies that you had your
knees done when you were a kid too,
right?
Yeah.
When I was 17 years old I had double
knee surgery.
So would you have done.
I just had arthroscopic,
a bone chips removed and stuff like
that.
Yeah.
But,
you know,
the thing is I've been in pain my whole
life,
you know,
and there was a certain point,
uh,
when I got the hip surgery that I wasn't
able to able to handle it anymore and
they started feeding me pills,
you know,
like crazy.
And I got into that really hardcore
because that was something that,
uh,
you know,
at first you do it because it helps the
pain and then after a while you do it
because it's fun.
So this is post bigger,
stronger,
faster.
After bigger,
stronger,
faster,
bigger,
stronger,
faster.
You get your double hip replacements and
then you had the pill problem.
Yeah,
I got hooked on drugs.
It's like,
you know,
you,
you never aspire to become a drug
addict,
but it happens.
And I'm a lot happened.
A lot of my friends had happened to a
lot of people doing a lot of people I
know think a lot.
You think a little bit of that had to do
with like the recovery because you had
both of them done rather than just like
one of them done at a time.
Yeah.
I would always suggest to anybody that
has to have double hip replacement
surgery,
we get one done at a time because at
least you have one side that's good and
the other side that heals.
He literally couldn't really move at
all.
I was sort of like in a point in my life
where I'm like,
you know what?
Just do it.
Who Cares?
Let's go in and didn't really think it
through that.
How old were you?
Thirty three at the time and who?
Jesus Christ.
Double Hip replacement at 33 and if you
don't know what a double hip replacement
means,
they cut off the top of the bone and
they literally have this long screw that
they drive into the meat of the bone
where the marrow is and it locks in
place.
This new fake hip,
right?
It's fucking gnarly shit.
My friend Graham Hancock had it done.
He was here six weeks later.
He wasn't even walking with a limp when
I was like,
this is crazy.
You
had a hip replacement complications with
mine,
so I'm on one of the sides.
Added had complications of getting it in
because they're like,
oh,
all this muscle from squatting your ass
is like a rock.
So they're trying to.
They had to pound it in with a hammer.
It looked like,
um,
I saw the surgery part of the surgery
back on camera and it looked like an
auto body shop fixing the car.
Yeah.
There's a video of Tito Ortiz getting.
Is a disc replaced in his neck?
She just got a disc fused.
I think you gotta.
I'm not sure it was a spacer or disc
replaced,
but they're fucking hammering on his
neck.
Like clink,
clink,
clink.
Went,
what the fuck?
That's his neck,
man.
That is insane.
So what does it feel like now?
Now actually the hips feel okay.
If I lift heavy,
I still like,
I'll still squat and dead lift.
I just can't go as heavy as I used to
have dead lifted up to 50 slash 50 with
two fake hips.
Jesus Christ.
Not a very good deadlift and mark's
world.
But you know,
for,
for having the surgery and everything,
it's okay.
And they're fine.
Like it doesn't mean they're built.
Did you tell the doctor like give me
some fucking series heavy duty ones,
road road shocks,
there a titanium,
you know,
and I had a lot of people say,
well why do you have to lift like that?
Why do you like,
you know,
people always want to concern
themselves,
but you're doing.
I'm like,
wait,
why do you feel you need,
you have to lift like that.
It's just something that's ingrained in
you.
You just like doing it.
If you had surgery and somebody told you
why you have to fight still why you have
to go because you have to.
Did you ask the doctor for a bigger
Dick?
That's an option.
Oh,
now when they cut you open,
where do they cut you?
A right on the.
On the side of your ass cheek Kinda.
Is it a giant scar that's like that big
like three or four inches.
Wow.
That's amazing.
You do all that work with three or four
inches?
Yeah.
Like I have a buddy who was on the US
ski team.
He was on the US ski team and uh,
he's had no bullshit,
I think 28 knee surgeries.
Wow.
Yeah,
he's got,
I'll show you the surface of his knees.
Skiing is not good for your knees.
He's had his knees resurfaced.
He's.
Yeah,
it's fucking gnarly.
Let me find this picture real quick and
I'll show it to you because it's,
it's one of those where I show people
and they go,
what am I looking at?
He um,
but anyway,
his scars on his knee,
it looks like,
like,
like you're gutting a fish,
like they go all the way down the side
of the knee and they opened it up and
this was just in the eighties.
My Dad has that.
My Dad has,
you know,
fake knees also and he's got those big
scars.
Fuck man.
Your Dad's got it rough.
He's a warrior Frankenstein that is a,
that's a lot of fucking surgery.
A lot of shit to get done on your body.
Yeah.
Fake News and fake hips.
So you think that you're gonna
eventually have to do that to the knees?
Yeah,
I like try to hold it off as long as
possible and I think that the best way
to go is uh,
trying new therapies like stem cells,
other things that are coming out.
Um,
I know that certain,
uh,
there's actually a gel that they can put
into knee,
uh,
the replaced cartilage.
Uh,
John,
I hadn't done.
It's like a,
it's a very advanced technique that,
you know,
they're just basically they use very
sparingly.
Well,
I know that they're doing,
they have this new meniscus surgery
they're doing where they're taking this
like a scaffolding and they implanted
inside where your meniscus,
she used to be in with these proteins in
it and somehow or another your body
grows meniscus in the scaffolding as it
make sense that they're able to do.
Now it's just amazing.
Let me show you.
This is my buddy's knee.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's the same guy that was on the US
ski team.
They cut them.
Steve Graham.
What's up brother?
They cut them.
Just kind of like fish.
It looks like steak and like two wedding
rings.
It's fucking gnarly.
Yeah,
it's pretty hardcore.
I'll send this to you,
Jamie,
so you can put it up on the uh,
it looks great.
Injuries are no joke,
you know?
Yeah.
No,
there are no drug.
Well,
this,
this guy too.
He's fucking crazy.
He's in his sixties.
He's still spars,
mma on a regular basis.
He's an animal.
He's a doctor.
Ophthalmologist doesn't give a fuck.
He's,
he's always been crazy.
He's just A.
I've known this guy for it.
He's a guy who talked me into doing
standup has always been an animal.
He's just,
uh,
it's just hard to imagine that.
That's Shit I saw you do stand up in
Sacramento,
but two years ago maybe.
Oh,
where was it at maybe three years ago?
Um,
I don't know,
like comedy store or some shit like
that.
Cool little upstairs comedy club.
That's a good spot.
They have the punchline,
right?
Yeah.
Yep.
Do you live up there?
I commando Sacramento.
Do you go to team Alpha male and watch
those?
You know,
I'm friends with those guys.
I haven't been over there a whole lot,
but I've seen you ride around.
I see those guys around a little bit
here and there and he's got a huge,
his own gym.
Huge Gym.
Okay.
Give it a plug.
What's the name of the gym?
The super training gym just in West
Sacramento,
but it doesn't matter because it's free.
Yeah,
it's kind of weird.
It's free.
The gym is free.
How's that work?
It doesn't,
it's not the smartest business models.
Not My brightest idea.
What a gym is free.
It's a way for me to,
um,
give back to power lifting.
It's predominantly a power thing
facility.
Um,
and I think that if other people had the
ability to make their gym free,
they probably would do it.
And so I'm in a position to make it for
free.
So I did.
Wow,
that's crazy.
That's a,
that's a beautiful thing.
Then you never hear that.
You usually find exact opposite to what
everybody asks for him.
Hey,
can you train me?
Can you train me?
He's like,
I don't train people.
I even do seminars and stuff a lot for
free.
I just did one at a deuces gym in Venice
and then a lot of times I'll do them to
some down in downtown La at the Barbell
Brigade,
but just if I'm in town somewhere,
I'll just,
uh,
I'll email email the owner of the gym to
say,
Hey,
I'd love to come in and teach your
people how to squat or deadlift.
And they're like,
okay,
well what does it cost?
I'm like,
it doesn't cost anything.
That's so crazy.
End The fucking do some work.
What makes you such a generous guy?
That's.
I just kind of have a passion for
inspiring people and not so much a just
instructing them because I think that
the main message is to get people moving
and get people doing shit rather than
just saying,
oh,
here's how you,
to people that we look up to you,
Louie Simmons,
you know,
Louis sent Pat Miletich has a free gym,
I don't know if he still has it,
but he had it free gym said to help
people do what you couldn't do when you
were younger.
You know,
that's,
it's great for,
for young folks.
There's the fucking knee and it's all,
it's good and you know,
uh,
to his,
what,
what ended up happening is people,
um,
I'll put up a post on instagram.
It could be of like me eating food or
some shit and somebody would say,
oh,
I got your slingshot,
I got your raps,
I got you're this,
you're that.
So it's like people are given back to me
anyway.
So it just,
um,
it's just another way for me to give
back to the community and for like a,
you said Reebok is,
is a brand of my company is not my
company is me.
And so the brand is growing and
sometimes people don't know that I'm
associated with it,
but nine times out of 10 they do know
I'm associated with it.
That's awesome man.
That's a,
that's a beautiful way of looking at
things.
I love it.
And because of that we were just
actually at the coffee bean next door
and these two guys wanted to take a
picture with them.
They're like,
they know who,
you know,
people know who he is.
Yeah.
And it's funny because you tons of free
videos,
youtube.com
backslash super training.
Oh six thousands of free videos on there
on how to squat,
deadlift bench,
that kind of shit.
Nice.
Now your new documentary is prescription
thugs.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And this is based on your experience and
getting hooked on pain pills after you
had your double hip replacement.
Yeah.
Sort of based on a lot of people's
experience,
you know,
after bigger,
stronger,
faster.
Our older brother passed away about
eight months after making that movie and
he had a really bad struggle with
prescription drugs,
mainly painkillers.
Uh,
and then it went to,
you know,
oxycotton when you could use it,
used to be able to crush it up and
inject it and all that,
stuff like that.
And he was getting into that kind of
stuff.
Um,
I don't know if he's injecting it,
but he was definitely snorting it and
different things like that.
He loved it all.
Yeah.
My parents found out about it and they
were obviously heartbroken and um,
helped him,
helps him get clean for awhile and then,
you know,
then you go back to it and back and
forth and back and forth.
And um,
it's just crazy because he,
after he got off all the pills,
sorta switched to alcohol,
you know,
and it was like alcohol a little bit.
Everything else,
a lot of weed,
a lot of alcohol and this and that,
you know,
just things that,
uh,
that when you're not in the right state
of mind or you're depressed or not the
best things for you,
you know.
And he ended up,
seemed like from the day he ended up
going down like a really bad,
a bad,
a bad spiral,
you know,
and he was on some psych meds to a for
depression and different things like
that.
And um,
he died in a sober living house with no
real explanation of how he died.
And uh,
we still don't really know exactly what
happened.
There was really no drugs found in his
system in a toxicology report and stuff
like that.
So it was just like,
to me something where,
uh,
you know,
this is an epidemic that hit home with
me,
uh,
after I saw my brother died and I was
like,
I will never go down that path and there
I am on the floor scrambling,
looking for like another Vicodin,
you know,
going,
I must've dropped one somewhere and just
knowing a lot of other people that went
through it,
I decided to pick up and make a movie
about it.
Now your brother in your bigger,
stronger,
faster.
Seemed like a very troubled guy.
Yeah.
Mad Dog.
He struggled with himself more so than
anything else.
He was bipolar and so all this stuff
sort of compounded that.
Yeah.
I think we get a prescription.
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but did he get a prescription for an
injury or how did he get it?
He was wrestling with the wwe who was
sort of a,
you know,
on the going,
doing,
doing the rounds.
And so if you've got a prescription but
he got drugs.
Yeah.
And they all got drugs.
When did he start wrestling for the wwe
pro?
Back in like 1990,
like early nineties and he wrestled
forever,
like he was always on tv or so,
93,
something like that.
He was always on TV and then he wrestled
all the way through.
I'm kind of up until he died.
Like he had some still some matches,
not really with wwe but with other
smaller federations and stuff like that.
So he kind of wrestled for a real long
time,
but he never really made it and that was
a really big problem for him,
you know,
it wasn't,
it wasn't good enough to be a good coach
or a good teacher.
He wanted to.
He wanted to make it.
He wanted to be.
I don't know if he knew exactly what he
was chasing.
So even if he obtained some of that
success,
I don't think he would even recognized
it along the way.
Point.
It's a really good point and I think a
lot of people,
yeah,
they,
it's hard to get satisfied with certain
things and so he was just,
he was troubled.
He,
you know,
the quote that's on the wall in my gym
is a from the film,
he says,
I'd rather be dead than average.
And that was uh,
something that he,
you know,
he just,
he couldn't live without,
um,
you know,
being with whatever his ideal for
success was.
And the problem I think that you really
just nailed though is that they don't
know what that is.
What's that goal,
what is that?
And if they don't ever reach it,
they never feel satisfied.
And the thing is that he be,
despite it all,
that he's like the nicest,
coolest guy in the world.
And we would have our backs,
you know,
on a,
on everything today.
You have good friends.
Yeah.
He had crazy emotional really what
everybody has,
right?
They have good friends and then they get
into drugs and then they don't have good
friends,
you know.
So you have a lot of enabling people,
a lot of people that will allow you to
keep doing what you're doing.
A lot of people that will put up with
your bullshit.
Uh,
my father wasn't one of them,
you know,
my father was somebody who like put his
foot down and was helping them get clean
and um,
you know,
we just weren't able to catch it in
time,
you know,
and so people that are listening to
this,
I think it's really important to talk
about these issues.
It's just a,
you know,
people want to always trying to push
these issues under the rug.
So if he knows someone who's struggling,
try your best to reach out to them and
just see if you can get to the bottom of
the problem.
I know it's the worst fucking thing in
the world to try to approach somebody
about it,
but see if you know,
whatever you think is a good way of
going about doing it and try to reach
out to the person because you don't know
how much longer it will be here for.
It's just so hard to get people to
listen to you though,
isn't it?
It's brutal.
It is,
yeah.
When you've been through it,
it becomes a different.
It completely becomes different.
So I,
I went through it,
I ended up,
um,
it's kind of crazy halfway through this
film that I was making relapsing and
started popping xanax and all sorts of
other stuff.
Film on prescription drugs.
You start relapsing?
Yes.
Wow.
What the fuck?
Right.
That's how crazy.
When did you do this film?
We finished it.
We finished it for Tribeca film
festival.
So that was like in May.
So you,
you relapsed like a year ago,
a year and five months ago.
Fuck.
And um,
I was popping xanax and stuff like that
because you know,
there's like,
filmmaking is not an easy business,
you know,
cause like if you were,
if you didn't have all this other stuff
going on,
you were just a comic and you were
trying to make it.
It's,
it's brutal.
You know,
the ups and downs and oh I have an
audition for something I've seen other
people be successful can really beat you
down,
fly by you that were like way behind
you,
you know,
all these different things that go on in
your head.
You feel like that about the documentary
world.
That's like people that were making some
documentaries that would do really well
and you get bummed out.
I wouldn't really get bummed out so much
about other people.
I try to always stay in my own lane and
think about myself,
but I get more bummed out putting the
pressure on myself.
Nobody elements do real well and you go,
God dammit,
why am I doing?
I could have done that.
Or somebody makes a documentary and then
they're like off to the races doing like
all these big movies and you know,
like,
why?
Why didn't somebody pick me for that?
You know,
like my documentary did way better than
that documentary or so you know,
those kinds of things in,
in your eyes.
But just the film world in general,
Hollywood in general gave me this
feeling of enact adequacy.
It gave me a feeling like I wasn't good
enough.
Like everything I did,
I wasn't making it and people go,
well you did this hit movie.
It was really big and like,
yeah,
but it didn't really make money at the
box office like it did really?
Which is a not your original intent.
Like when he made the film,
he said,
I want a lot of people to see the movie.
Tons of people seeing your language.
When you say it gave you this feeling of
inadequacy,
but isn't that maybe the way you
approached it yourself?
I mean,
it seems obvious giving you anything,
right?
I made that up in his own head.
In your own head,
you feel inadequate.
You feel like,
Oh man,
you know,
I,
and as many as many people tell you that
you do good,
you're still looking for,
like you said,
you're still searching for that thing.
So for me it was all about finding
balance.
So when I relapsed and realize I need
help,
that's A.
I reached out.
I didn't really reach out.
But once I,
once I knew I needed help and everybody
sort of figured me out,
my girlfriend helped me a lot with it.
Um,
she sort of found me a really fucked up
one day,
a drunk and on,
on Xanax in the middle of the night.
And uh,
she called me.
I don't really answer my phone a whole
lot.
Um,
I don't respond to it,
a ton,
rings a lot and I get a lot of messages
and shit,
so I'm not really a on my phone that
much for that kind of stuff,
but I noticed a number of was odd and it
was probably like about midnight,
so it was like,
it just seems kind of weird.
That's not like a telemarketer,
you know,
like calling it like 7:00
PM or something.
This is something different and for
whatever reason,
I didn't have her number in my phone,
um,
but it was from like Pennsylvania or
something,
I think where she's originally from.
And uh,
it was lauren and she said,
you know,
your brother is blah,
blah,
blah.
And I couldn't understand what she was
saying.
She was very,
very,
a very sad and crying and stuff.
And so I asked her to kind of calmed
down and I'm kind of assess the
situation a little bit.
And she said,
I think your brother's in,
in his,
uh,
apartment.
I think he's passed out.
Um,
I said,
well,
you're the only one there.
You got to kind of go in and,
you know,
see what's,
she's like,
I don't know how I'm going to find them
or,
and I was Kinda like,
Whoa,
like,
what do you mean you don't know how
you're going to find them because I
don't,
I didn't know how bad the situation was
or how serious it was.
I did know his friend,
his friend called me a few times that,
hey man,
you know,
your brothers,
he's fucking up with some pills and
doing this and that here and there.
Um,
and then,
uh,
you know,
then then I would communicate with that
person again and I'd find out that he's
doing a little bit better and then he'd
be doing a little bit worse.
So it Kinda went back and forth and you
know,
having my other brother died from it.
I was like,
fuck man,
I don't even know.
I don't have the energy to fucking go
down that road again.
You know,
I want to reach out to him.
I want to talk to him.
I do love him.
He's a hero and an idol to me and a lot
of ways and uh,
I really did want to reach out to them,
but I just didn't know how to fucking
bring it up,
but,
you know,
he was really suffering and I didn't
really realize how bad it was until she
called.
And then I got off the phone with her.
I just said,
you know,
take his keys away and make sure he's
okay.
Talk to my wife,
my wife's fucking awesome.
She's super supportive about all this
kind of stuff.
And she said,
we need to fly him here tomorrow,
you know.
And I said,
well,
let's fly lauren here to make sure he
gets on the fucking flight,
that he's not drinking or taking pills
or doing something crazy and he misses
his flight.
So we flew both of them up.
We're able to get him some treatment
where he was able to,
uh,
work on starting to recover.
It's a nasty path,
you know,
it's,
um,
did you document this in the film?
I didn't document all the stuff that
went down,
like leading up to it,
but yeah,
it's,
it's in the film we talk about it for
sure.
Um,
but like I said,
it's a nasty path that like,
it's like a snowball effect,
you know what I mean?
And looking,
looking at it now,
it's like,
I mean it's not funny ever but it's like
laughable how like,
what the fuck was I thinking,
you know,
I can see it now from a different point
of view.
So you said you relapsed on Xanax.
So was it just you were having anxiety?
No,
I mean I think that it's just whatever,
you know,
you just like to take it because a,
it may,
you know,
you can't sleep.
My,
my mind is always racing.
There's always another idea in the head
and there's always,
I can't go to sleep,
you know?
So I've tried the float,
the float chambers.
I've tried stuff like that.
I can't even get my mind to stop
thinking a lot of times or so I thought
so.
I always thought that I needed
something,
whether it was alcohol,
whether it was pills,
and I realized through the whole journey
that all I really needed was to believe
in myself again to believe in who I
really was and what I started doing when
I started out trying to make films in
the first place and tell the truth and
be honest.
The problem was I couldn't be honest
with myself.
I had a real hard time being honest with
myself and that's what a recovery has
has brought to me.
It's,
uh,
it's amazing to be able to know how much
he's allowed to talk about the film,
but I'll talk about it a little bit.
He,
uh,
yeah,
he basically interviewed somebody for
the film.
Uh,
the ended up helping him.
He interviewed this guy,
Richard Tate,
who,
uh,
owns a treatment center in Malibu and
he,
for his film,
he researched it and they had like a 95
percent success rate with people that
were there I think for over 60 days or
something like that,
90 days,
90 days.
And he was like,
what the fuck?
Ninety five percent success rate.
That's crazy.
The whole time I'm interviewing the guy,
I'm like,
I wish I could come here.
I wish I could come here because I knew
that I still had a problem with alcohol
and um,
I wasn't really doing xanax at the time,
but like he researched it for himself.
He's trying to tell him stuff.
He's researching for the film,
but he's researched.
Weird thing,
man.
You start like looking,
did you go to this place?
Yeah.
I ended up going to cliffside Malibu for
90 days.
So what do they do that so successful?
They just change your life about
everything.
But Richard Tate was a wild man himself
and he gave me.
Here's the thing,
when you have a guide telling you,
listen,
14 years ago I was on my couch smoking
crack with a hooker on each side.
I was oiled up for some reason.
Smoking,
cigar,
smoking,
crack,
you know,
and those,
a good time.
Yeah.
And it tells you,
you know,
that eight of his friends come and knock
on his door and try to get him sober and
he slams his door the door in his face.
And then,
uh,
he's like,
you know what,
that was rude.
He goes back and opens the door.
He goes,
what day is it?
And they said,
it's Friday.
And he goes,
come back on a Monday.
And he slams the door.
They come back on Monday.
He was like,
at that point,
just done doing drugs and alcohol and,
uh,
they took them to treatment.
I'm like,
man,
if this guy can get better.
Like I wasn't doing,
I wasn't,
I wasn't that bad,
but I didn't have hookers.
Yeah,
at least I didn't know.
What did they do for you?
What is,
what is the process of getting someone
to get 95 percent of people staying
clean?
First part is a separation from the
problem.
Uh,
just just being away from drugs and
alcohol I think like Aa is a great
thing,
but for me,
if I would have went to an AA meeting,
I would have went home and drank that
night.
I needed to be.
For me,
I needed to be in a place where I
couldn't get isolated.
I needed to be isolated from it for a
little while to get away from it.
Uh,
the main,
the main thing was therapy.
It's all therapeutic.
It's all like group therapy.
He goes sit in a group with people that
are fucked up and you talk about your
problems and in a,
in a good facility,
they had such good counselors there that
they,
these people,
like it was a,
it was more about like being loved
again,
feeling part of your,
you know,
I moved to La and I was on my own.
I moved to La when I was 19 years from,
from New York.
My whole family was back east.
My brother moved out here,
eventually my older brother moved out of
here eventually and eventually my
parents moved out here and we do have a
close family too.
We have a really close family.
So to be away from your family and this
whole time and not feel like any love
from the world is a tough thing,
you know,
and like a lot of people don't really
express that,
you know,
might sound kind of wimpy or something
like that.
But it's true.
We didn't,
there was no feeling of comfort or
safety or security in anything that I,
that I did.
So like regaining that through being
around people with like minded
experiences and there's just some
counselors there that will break you.
You know,
there,
there's people that go there,
hardcore heroin addicts that like will
sit there and in group therapy and not
want to be analyzed,
you know,
and these guys don't break them down
until they're,
you know,
punching pillows and shit saying this is
my father and fucking piece of Shit,
you know,
that's how it goes.
It's like,
it's a really intense,
a therapeutic thing.
Uh,
that allows you to see yourself in a
different way and it's a very humbling.
The number one thing is like,
uh,
the number one thing that I had on my
side was a desperation to get better.
That was one of the fucked up parts of
the film.
Bigger,
stronger,
faster.
Was Your Dad saying they knew that your
older brother was going to die that way
and to go through that and then have
your brother die that way and then for
you to get hooked on pills yourself
that,
that hadn't been a helpless feeling.
Like that's why I felt like I couldn't
tell anybody.
So I went to my parents and I was doing
an interview with them and I really
wanted to tell him,
but I was like,
you know,
I don't know if I can tell them.
So early on in the movie before I,
before I had relapsed,
I said,
hey,
listen,
I had a problem with this.
My mom cries.
And she's like,
well,
why didn't you tell me?
I'm like,
how am I supposed to tell you?
You just lost a son.
I'm going to tell you like I'm going to
go,
you know,
next year you're going to worry about me
because I'm not there.
You know what is.
If you can try to describe what is the
feeling like when you want to take that
shit,
when you want to take a pain pill,
like what?
What is.
There is no feeling.
It's a,
it's,
it's not.
It's not the addicts fault.
Like you might have,
you know,
friends or people that you know that I
want to just wake up and stop drinking.
Well you can't.
It's not your fault anymore.
It's a,
it's a pathway,
a neurological pathway.
You just talked about before Brock
Lesnar,
somebody got a hold of them and built
those punches and kicks into his system.
Right?
It becomes ingrained and built in your
system.
It becomes a neurological pathway in
your brain and you tend to habituate the
things that make you feel good.
You know?
So that's just something that an addict
will do more so than other people.
You're saying that this is very distinct
black and white thing,
that it's not the,
the,
the addicts fault,
but the addict has to be sober first
before they can get fucked up.
Right.
So you're sober,
you're sober,
you have a conscious mind,
you're aware of your actions and decide
to take a pain pill.
How is that not the addicts fault?
If you're already addicted?
It's,
it's an automatic thing.
Your body feels like it needs it.
Okay.
You,
we're an addicted maybe because he never
got actual treatment.
How do you get addicted in the first
place,
but you weren't because you were off of
it for a long time.
Right.
So it wasn't like he had this mad need,
like your bones were aching.
You had to get that.
I think you switched to alcohol I think
is kind of the part that you're at.
Yeah,
I switched to alcohol like instead of
having pills,
so I always had something.
So you get the double hip replacement
surgery.
So you did your documentary bigger,
stronger,
faster was 2008.
So right after that,
2009.
Like when are you talking about?
You're getting your hip replaced in
2009.
Okay.
Six years ago.
And then how you get off the shit?
Our 2007.
I actually got to replace.
I got it done before we finished the
movie.
Okay.
Oh you did 2017.
But then.
But then I didn't mention this.
So then I had um,
my hip,
they said,
I said they had complications.
I had,
they had to Redo my hip.
Oh.
So two years later they,
we did it in 2009.
They redid my right hip.
They completely took it out and put it
back together.
Oh my,
screw it.
Well,
there's some messed up parts in there
that they have to unscrew that thing
that I think they left that.
I think that was fine.
I think it's the other part that was
messed up.
And then a month after I had that hip
surgery,
my brother died,
you know,
and it's just tough.
It's just,
you know,
it's like you can,
you can power through that stuff if you
have the tools.
But I didn't have any tools to stay
sober or let me ask you this.
So you get the hip replacement surgery
the first time,
then you get hooked on pills,
then you get off pills,
but two years later they want to reopen
you up.
Do you take pills again?
And got back on pills for how long?
About another two years.
And then,
and then what happened was,
so then I went I fucking years.
Yeah.
So then I went back to uh,
to try to get off the pills.
Like I knew I needed to get off the
pillow long.
Where you want them for the first time.
The first time when you had the first
problem a I was on them almost.
I was on them for like a year and then I
got off of him,
uh,
for how long,
but I only got off them for a couple
months and I had the second surgery
again.
So it was a really gotten off of them.
It's a really up and down.
Thanks.
So the drug called suboxone and suboxone
sort of mimics the way that a painkiller
will feel in your body.
Uh,
but it doesn't have.
Well it doesn't,
it doesn't get you high.
It'll just basically making it not feel
sick.
So that's the biggest problem is
withdrawals.
You feel so bad.
It's like the flu times 100.
So the thing is that when you're coming
off of them and you want to get on
suboxone.
So my,
my insurance would cover all the pills
so there was 10 bucks a pop,
you know,
10 bucks for like 180 pills of percocet
or vicodin or whatever the drug I was
taken when I wanted to get off of them,
I had to consult with a doctor every
month for $250 and I had to pay about
225 to $250.
The drug and insurance doesn't cover any
of that.
They don't cover you getting better,
they only cover you doing the dangerous
drugs.
That's another brutal thing on top of
it,
you know?
And then suboxone I think that is.
Do you think that's built into the
system?
Do they sell more drugs built into the
So that's a scary thought,
if that's true.
Yeah.
That they absolutely like if you look at
it,
if you want to.
If it's like,
you know,
like yes,
if you take painkillers,
it's your fault for getting addicted,
kind of.
But if you actually look at the history
of Oxycontin,
that drug was designed to hook people on
what's basically very similar to heroin.
You know,
it's,
it's uh,
it,
the drug company that makes it,
that made it purdue pharmaceuticals,
they,
they lied,
you know,
they made $8,000,000,000
on this drug,
right?
$8,000,000,000.
And then they had to pay a fine of
$2,000,000,000.
So like,
look at the profit,
still $6,000,000,000.
They call it the price of doing
business,
you know,
so they lied and said that you will not
get addicted using this drug.
Well,
they got the whole country addicted to
this drug,
you know,
it was,
those people should all be in prison.
They got the whole,
the whole country addicted to a drug
that's made for like severe cancer
patients,
you know.
And that kind of stuff is,
is this criminal?
And people go like,
oh,
well you should have known.
It's like most people don't know.
That's why we're making a movie.
To have awareness,
you know,
for these things.
So this is really fresh for you.
This is not something that you have
overcome a long time ago.
No,
no.
I still go to meetings and I still stay
up on it.
I think every day you need to remind
yourself that you can go back there.
So you're 100 percent sober now.
You don't fuck with no.
Nothing.
So the feeling that you get like when,
when you,
when you have this relapse with a Xanax,
that feeling that you get,
is it just,
you just feel helpless?
Like what do you do?
You feel just pulled to it?
Like what do you.
What's pulling?
Yeah,
like for example,
so xanax was a drug that would help me,
I would drink a lot,
you know,
like I wasn't because because I was an
addict why he'd,
he'd kind of drank to the point where,
you know,
it was a compromising the next day type
of thing.
And then also you ended up in the
hospital a couple of times from
drinking.
Yeah.
I would say serious bouts of drinking,
but it wasn't like he really knows this,
but I went to the,
to the uh,
urgent care or emergency room I think 10
times within a matter of like 20 days.
What's,
yeah,
because I go to urgent care and I'd go
get xanax because I had a hangover so
bad because I would drink so much,
you know,
and it was continuous like every day.
So for me it became,
it became a labor.
It became like everyday I was like,
you know,
uh,
this cat chasing its tail.
I,
I ever get better or feel better at
first.
You weren't drinking that often though,
right?
No,
at first it was like every three days,
seven days,
you know,
we talked about it,
power lifting and everything like that.
We were sports guys,
like we were never into drinking,
were never into drugs.
Like
that wasn't something even on my radar
when I did bigger,
stronger,
faster,
I would drink,
you know,
here and there.
But I should have known back then
because like when I did drink it was
like binge drinking and that's when you
know that you'll probably have a problem
somewhere down the road if you're the
guy that drinks and you got the guy that
drinks once a month,
but you get completely hammered,
you know that you might have a problem.
You know,
I wasn't the guy that could ever put it
down.
So how,
what does it feel like to make a
documentary about prescription drugs
while you're hooked on prescription
drugs?
A guilty really guilty the whole time.
Like I had raised the money to do it.
That was moving forward with it.
Had a bunch of people involved.
So I'm like,
who the fuck do I tell?
You know,
you're in this weird situation where
you're like,
I'm a hypocrite but I can't stop what I
just stopped doing this and pull the
plug and I have people working for me.
People editing the film.
A partner Greg young was there since the
very beginning and he was,
you know,
he knew what was going on,
but he didn't know was going to do to
like pull the plug on his own job and
he,
he didn't,
he cared about me and wanted to help me,
but he didn't know how to help me.
You know,
how much of a part of the film does this
become a,
it's,
it's sort of a,
towards,
towards the end.
Uh,
it's sort of like in the,
in the third act of the film,
you know,
we sort of discuss it and go into it.
Uh,
we didn't go into a whole lot about
recovery because of the movie isn't
really about that,
but anyway,
by the end of the movie,
you know,
I'm okay.
And if a whole quarter,
a whole quarter of a year,
you know,
that's crazy.
They,
they take you away from society for very
few people can afford to do that.
No,
it's crazy man.
And what happened was,
uh,
if I feel this,
I feel almost everybody,
if they could unplug from their life for
like 30 days,
even like 10 days,
like people go on vacation,
they still bring your phone and stuff.
A lot of people around them that they
know and it's supposed to be in that
environment of solitude is just like an
amazing feeling that I'm though dark.
Yeah.
Going dark,
what happened to me was in the,
so yes,
how they helped me and um,
I could tell you that I think part of it
a big huge part of it and they've talked
about like Aa and all these other
programs and everything ever talks about
a spiritual awakening.
So the third day that I was in Rehab,
I went and took a shower and it was like
4:00
in the morning or something.
I couldn't even,
I couldn't sleep or anything.
And I went in the shower and I just
cried for like three hours.
The fuck am I doing.
I went to USC film school,
I went,
I did all the right things.
I,
I trained my whole life.
I did everything the right way and I'm
fucking blowing it and that's what got
to me,
you know,
it was my self that got to me.
It wasn't,
it wasn't anybody else really.
You know,
another thing that happened to them in
treatment was a cliff side.
Malibu is beautiful,
multimillion dollar facility.
It's a,
it's really nice.
It's in fucking Malibu,
California,
which is beautiful.
But I think once you were there for like
two weeks,
they took you away from there and three
and some shit hole.
Right?
Yeah.
What happened was that,
so I was there for.
I personally think it's all part of the
plan,
but I don't know.
Yeah,
I was there for 10 days and um,
and after 10 days,
uh,
I was being helped by the facility.
They,
they were,
they were funding it.
They were helping me.
So,
um,
since they were helping me out because I
was part of this movie and the guy just
had compassion for me,
Richard Tate and wanted to see me get
better.
The guy was suspicious that you had a
problem when you came here the first
time to interview them anyway.
Right,
exactly.
And so,
so he said to me,
we can't afford to keep you here
anymore.
It's 60 grand a month to go to that
place.
Jesus Christ,
a lot of insurance covers it,
you know,
and things like that.
Yeah,
insurance covers that.
It depends on your double scam.
So it's the fucking insurance covers
that they may go.
It's all part of the system.
So it's all part of the system in some
box money for that.
Yeah.
So it's hard to come up with that money.
I need money for that.
Sorry.
Yeah.
But the,
but they have the money for the
treatment.
Everything.
So anyway,
throw you in this place.
That's not so good.
So what happened was I went to a place
called Claire Foundation.
It's in Santa Monica and it's very
industrial.
It's a,
it's a government run Rehab facility.
Uh,
and it's,
I mean I walked in there and saw this
guy with no teeth and he was scratching
his nuts and he's like,
you're not going to like it in here.
The pillows are really tough,
you know,
and I walk in,
I'm like,
where the fuck do you sleep in here?
And I'm looking and there's all these
bunk beds.
I'm like,
well where's my room?
And I'm like,
no,
there is no room.
It's one big room with 40 bunk beds and
40 grown men and 39 of them just got out
of jail and you're the only one.
It's normal kind of,
you know,
it was sort of a facility like that.
Whereas this is something out of like
one flew over the cuckoo's nest and when
they put me in there that was like,
fuck this man this,
you know,
I know like a lot of addicts will say
like,
I'm not like that and I'm not like this.
This was something that was so far
fetched from where I would ever find
myself in my life so far down that I was
like,
fuck this,
I'm getting Outta here and this is it.
I'm never going to drink or do a drug
again.
And it'll hopefully,
hopefully you can stick to that,
you know?
Um,
but I don't have any urges to anymore.
But it was that facility that um,
that really cemented it,
you know,
after that's the only 10 days,
so why I was in that facility for 19
days and it was like about 10 days in 10
days,
19 days there.
And then,
and then when I got,
when they had ruined for me back at
cliffside and it ended up going back to
Malibu and like living out the rest of
it in Malibu.
And what was really nice about that was
I was still able to work,
so I was going to treatment every day
for three hours in the morning and then
I would drive to la and I would,
I would work on the movie the rest of
the time.
It's pretty twisted,
but it all worked out,
you know.
But you pretty much feel like you were
done after you went to that shit hole,
right?
Yeah.
But you just felt like you needed more
treatment to cement it is like,
what's the thought process,
you know,
like,
uh,
it's hard.
It's hard
to explain to people that haven't been
through it.
Um,
people have been through it.
They know what it's like a,
but addiction addiction is one of the
most powerful forces in this universe.
It's one of the,
it's something that drives people
everyday to do bad shit,
you know,
and continued support,
right?
Yeah.
You basically just need.
Basically,
like a lot of it's set off by trauma,
like things that happened in your life.
A lot of it's uh,
you know,
but I didn't really have that like one
main trauma that like set it off.
People go,
well,
your brother died.
I was like,
well that was,
it wasn't as dramatic as it sounds like.
It.
Of course it's a traumatic but.
But I was,
I was doing stuff before that.
So what was before that?
I don't even know.
Maybe the hip surgery didn't seem to me.
I think a big part of it for me was
having the hip surgery took away
something that I really loved,
which was like lifting,
you know,
something that like,
if you couldn't fight anymore,
you'd fucking hate it.
You know,
you'd be like bombed,
grumpy because there was a part of it
just in your everyday life and now it's
gone.
Yeah,
and it might sound stupid,
but it's part is,
it's something that you do,
you know,
if I said,
hey joe,
you know what,
no more fighting bro.
You're done.
So you just felt like just a giant loss.
You just felt like something was missing
from your life and that's what led you
to just start getting fucked up,
fill it in with other stuff,
you know.
Wow.
When you didn't think about maybe like
trying something healthy and trying to
engineer your life and sort of a way or
we do something.
Okay.
So when you take away working out what's
healthy,
what you couldn't do any working out?
Not,
I mean not a whole lot.
not like I used to and now that long,
I mean just just for like years.
I just,
I just felt shitty,
you know,
I just didn't feel good.
I'm the hips.
Yeah.
I think he also felt lonely too.
I mean,
you know,
he,
he didn't have her until more recently
and even though our family is in
California,
you know,
I have two children,
so our parents moved to this.
They were from New York originally.
They moved to California,
but we all live in northern California
and when it came to like holidays and
some different things,
I mean we'd call them and communicate
with them a little bit here and there.
But you know,
he kind of just seemed like he didn't
give a fuck about.
Still in upstate New York.
I know he's here.
He's in La.
Yeah.
So he was only in La and we were in
Sacramento but um,
it wasn't,
you know,
not that far.
It's one hour flight or whatever.
But we'd communicate with them here and
there and just,
you know,
even like on his birthday or something,
call them or whatever the case might be.
Um,
and then he would come up to Sacramento
or I'd come down here and we'd meet up
with each other here or there,
but we just didn't really realize how
severe the situation was in terms of
just is like mental health,
you know,
it's just like not a dude thing to do.
Like,
hey man,
how you doing?
And somebody isn't just like poor out
there fucking feelings were like,
oh,
I'm doing good.
You know,
they just leave it at that and you kind
of move onto the next thing.
I have people that are in my film that
have relapsed,
you know,
since the film.
Um,
and I have people that,
I have a guy who,
uh,
I had to get a release for the film,
like somehow somebody slipped up and
didn't,
didn't get released for the film and I'm
just like,
this is like two days ago,
I have a guy who who relapsed and he's
all fucked up.
We're trying to get a release of the
film.
We can't even get in touch with them.
So I did send somebody to his house and
then we found out that he's relapsed and
he's a mess and he needs treatment too.
So it's like this,
it's a dangerous,
powerful thing.
And,
and part of the whole program is helping
other people and I think it's beautiful.
It's like the thing now is like,
how do I help other people,
how do I help?
The people will listen to this show and
they will hit me up on facebook and
they'll say,
listen man,
I'm an alcoholic.
I'm a drug addict,
drug addict,
what do I do?
And the beauty is I don't have to do it
for them.
I can just lead them in the right
direction and help guide them to
treatment and be there for them.
The people that run these treatment
centers,
muscle,
they must feel like they're like
combating vampires or something.
Everyone is just getting bitten and
sick.
It's,
it's incredible.
The second get sick is a good way of
putting it.
You know,
like when somebody has something like
that,
you kind of feel like they have cancer
or something and you don't know how to
help him.
I think I'm,
a lot of people just think,
oh,
I can help him.
Like hey,
if we go like work out together,
if we hang out together,
if we go eat together,
like that should be fun and like take
his mind off it,
but it doesn't work that way as soon as
you turn back in a way.
I think also vampire.
Yeah.
I mean,
and looking at it people say,
oh it's not a news is your own fucking
fault.
Your own personal.
Take all that away.
Well,
what's going on?
Someone's got some shit in their veins
and they need to keep pumping into their
body.
It's like sick.
It is sick.
You know what?
All those same people that say it's not
a sickness.
And I like a lot of those people will
fall into it too,
you know,
like,
so.
Well that's what's fucked up about it.
How many people fall into it?
I've had a lot of friends get hooked on
pills.
Chris Lievens in my movie.
Busy.
Yeah.
He's had some issues and has had some
issues recently.
I just spoke to him,
um,
a couple of days ago and he's,
he's on a back on the suboxone and
again,
um,
and,
and it's hard to get off of that shit.
Like it's really hard to get off and
it's like suboxone is a maintenance drug
to keep them going back from doing,
to do in the axes.
But it's just something that like he's
going to have to battle and fight
everyday to get off.
What are the numbers like how many
people in this country are addicted to
pain pills?
I think it's like two point something
million shuffled to shit.
Fuck yeah.
Well and then just how many people are
just on pills period.
I mean,
I know some people,
uh,
some of the,
you know,
obviously some of the pharmaceutical
drugs,
so the benefit one,
but you want a number,
that's a real number.
You want a number of million people are
hooked on pain pills.
People walking around like zombies say
you had an idea to help people.
Holy Shit,
I'm just freaking out.
I can't believe that's real.
2 million people are hooked on that
Shit.
Yeah,
that's like a national epidemic.
Absolutely.
That's almost one percent of the
population of the country.
Last year I think 300 million people.
I think that's,
that's A.
God damn it.
2 million fucking people.
Three people is one percent in 2012.
Like the Lazy Q,
One hundred and 54 million.
Two hundred $54 million
prescriptions were written for Vicodin.
Fuck.
So that,
that's enough to Medicaid.
Say that again.
Say that number $254 million
prescriptions for Vicodin were written
in like last year or the year before.
And that's enough drugs,
that's enough painkillers to medicate
every male or every.
Every adult person in America for a
month.
So yeah,
250,
$4 million.
Here's another,
another step.
Four hundred and $54 million
prescriptions were filled.
Is that the idea for,
for painkillers?
Yeah.
How does that even make sense?
That's in a whole year and a whole year
because people get several,
so they get a bit windy pills or get a
lot of times.
It's like once a month,
you know,
they a lot of times with stuff like
that,
you want to get like 10 at a time though
too.
Well,
here's another step for you.
If you wanted to do something about it
and you're a congressman,
right?
And you're like,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm going to do something about this
epidemic.
And then there's $445,000
sitting on your table.
I can either take that money from
lobbyists because on average that's how
much money the lobbyists will take.
On average,
there's a certain amount of number of
people in Congress and a certain amount
of money that's spent.
So if you average it out,
it comes out to like over $400,000
per congressman that they use for their
campaigns and everything else.
So you can either take that money and
just say,
you know what,
everything's cool,
you know,
or you can take that money and try to
fight them and risk losing that money
out of your campaign.
So all these special interests and all
these different things that people talk
about all the time.
A pharmaceuticals is one of the biggest
ones to the one of the biggest
contributors to these campaigns.
So people don't really have a vested
interest to stop it.
They have no interest.
Right.
I mean that's an any of.
They weren't trying to fight it.
If they fought it with that little
amount of money,
it wouldn't even fucking work there.
Well,
how,
what amount of money would be affective?
Yeah.
Billions.
Like it's so intense.
What's really fucked up is this.
This shit didn't even exist 50 years
ago.
Right.
That's what's really fucked up.
It didn't really exist 20 years ago or
how nuts is that something.
So we'll do.
Twenty years ago they did have quail.
Ooh,
because the big bill cosby drugged right
thing.
But are they as addictive?
They were a completely different thing.
From what I understand.
And this is just a total new level of
addictive properties,
right?
Yeah.
It's a.
So if you,
if you look at um,
okay,
so we have drugs like morphine,
right?
Morphine and heroin are like really
closely related.
You can make one out of the other,
right?
Uh,
but on the other side,
they,
they now make them synthetically.
So this shit doesn't even require.
They just chemical upon chemical upon
chemical.
It doesn't require any sort of a base.
If you don't read,
you don't need opium to make it,
you need opium and morphine,
but you don't need it to make oxycotton.
So they figured out a way to make these
things synthetically so that they can
just,
you know,
I don't understand that well,
how does that work?
I don't understand it either.
Like where are they getting the raw
properties that would make it and I was
happy,
but I don't know what the fuck they make
it from.
But like you can't make something out of
nothing physically.
That's why I always understood.
I didn't understand.
Like everyone said bullying,
Afghanistan produces,
you know,
90 whatever percent of the world's opium
and heroin.
But what about pills?
If it's synthetic opium or synthetic
heroin,
what are they getting it from
Afghanistan?
Is that they've figured out ways special
with ways to make it out of other things
that are like normal basis and changes
the chemical makeups of them somehow.
I don't know exactly what.
You're stupid for this conversation.
So opiates,
people goes,
oh yeah,
he's on opiates,
but that's not really true.
Unless he's on morphine,
they're on opioids which are synthetic
kinda like steroids,
steroids,
opioid.
See all of that boils.
Hemorrhoids.
How strange band that we live in a world
where 200 million prescriptions for
super highly addictive pain pills to get
prescribed in a year and we're supposed
to be like an educated country.
Think that like that's an epidemic for
prescribing to the kids and we're giving
kids,
you know,
adderall or given you the adderall,
Ritalin.
And that's like,
you know,
5 million prescriptions written for that
for kids every year,
you know,
just keeps going up and up and up.
It seems so easy to get shit too.
I had a mom,
I had to have a mom and my film and she
has a daughter that has adhd and so she
brings you to the psychiatrist or
whatever and they prescribe her adhd
pills,
you know,
adderall.
And the mom starts taking it and then a
mom convinces the daughter she doesn't
have adhd and she shouldn't take it.
So then the mom starts taking the other
kids.
There's three other kids.
She took all her kids to the doctor and
got like four prescriptions every month
and was taken like tons of adderall.
She would take like 10 a day.
I bet that bitch got a lot done.
Yeah.
Houses clean,
2010 every American adult every four
hours for one month.
It says every prescription painkiller
were prescribed to medicate every
American adults for every four hours.
What do you mean?
What does that mean?
You can't see that line?
Well,
why don't you make it so I can see it?
Here's sorry.
Oh,
it's like.
It's like,
oh,
there's the.
There's the text of it.
Okay.
In 2000,
10 enough,
prescription painkillers were prescribed
to medicate every American adult every
four hours for a month.
I wasn't lying Christ.
So.
So it's like three pills a day or
substance abusers.
That's 2010.
Now,
has it gotten better or worse in five
years?
Well,
it either way.
You know that numbers when I talked
about a purdue pharmaceuticals and
oxycontin and how that invaded America
and all that,
stuff like that.
If you look at it,
the government,
at some certain point I got fed up with
it and I said,
listen,
people are dying,
right?
So it's cool that you guys are selling
all these drugs and everything.
We'll take your lobby money,
but people are dying so you can't take
this drug.
You got to make a way that you can't
take it and crush it up anymore and
inject it or snort it or do other things
with it recreationally.
So now if you crush oxycotton,
it turns into a Gel.
It turns into like a Bush.
So,
uh,
what they did was after seeing what
happened,
did they figured out how you couldn't
crush it and snort it anymore?
Once they did that,
the sales dropped 80 percent.
So what does that tell you?
It's 80 percent just shows you that
anything is possible with money though.
How the fuck did they figure out a way
that if you crush it up,
it turns into a gel.
I don't know.
Someone talked them into doing that and
then they dropped 80 percent of their
profits and they stuck with it.
Yeah,
they're probably fucking scramble.
There are studies to show that that Gel
is less effective,
but they,
they find they find other ways to the
pills.
But here's the problem.
Here's the problem with a study,
right?
So everybody wants to think that they
read the studies and the studies are
good and the studies are valid and you
know,
what happens is you need to studies that
prove that you're a pill is more
effective than a placebo.
Not effected,
not more effective than anything that's
on the market.
Just more effective than a placebo to
get your drug past.
So it takes,
it costs a lot of money and a lot of
money through the FDA and a lot of
testing and all these things,
but it's still not very hard to get a
drug past.
They just passed one called [inaudible].
I said [inaudible] I hydro and it's like
way more powerful than oxycontin.
So now there's another drug on the
market that's more powerful.
Who are these fucking monsters?
How do we get some of that shit?
Who are these monsters that are making
this stuff?
Does anybody need something stronger
than Oxycontin?
Some fucking rallying cry for pain pills
to talk.
You talk about like,
um,
medical marijuana.
I talked to a senator about medical
marijuana.
Medical marijuana is not killing
anybody.
And,
and I'm like,
exactly.
So,
so is that something that's a,
you know,
good or bad,
and we look at it and go like,
man,
like it's,
it's crazy what we could do with a plant
compared to what's happening with,
uh,
you know,
what's happening with these pills.
I don't know anybody.
I know maybe one or two people that have
ruined their life,
you know,
with pot,
just because they're fucking lazy,
but beyond that,
beyond the scope of that,
it seems to be very helpful for so many
people.
Yeah.
My point of view has always been the,
if you pot ruins your life just because
pot got there first.
Yeah.
Exact cheeseburgers or scratch tickets
or the fucking job as witnesses.
Whoever gets to your commander and
alcohol is the fucking worst.
Alcohol's the devil.
If you do any of them,
if you indulge in it or you know you
don't have the gene for it or whatever
it is and that's not the worst.
You just have a drink and then you don't
want to have a drink anymore.
Yeah.
I've never had the urge to drink.
I like a drink every now and then,
but I've never had the urge is the same
way,
but I have friends who have it and I see
it.
It hits them and it's like a blanket
goes over their eyelids.
It's like they vanish so they're not
there anymore.
And then some new persons and those are
the people that you know are going to
eventually have a problem if they don't
already,
if they don't already.
Yeah.
I definitely have known a lot of
alcoholics and I know a lot of people
like more,
more than half a dozen people whose
lives have been wrecked by pills.
They just usually a back injury,
you know,
something along those lines.
And then they take something and the
next thing you know,
they can't get off it.
It's very innocent.
You know,
it's not a,
it's not something that's.
But it turns somebody who can be a great
person and just somebody who lies,
cheats and steals.
And that's what's wrong with it.
You know,
the pills.
Yeah.
I always just used to think like,
well if I could just be on these forever
because I still have a lot of pain in my
back and my hips.
And like not in the hips and the state,
but like in the lower back because of
the hips were messed up and because of
my knees are messed up and solve a lot
of pain.
But I know that what happens with the
pain pills are it's diminishing returns.
Like after awhile I'll need,
you know,
for awhile it was,
I had to take 12 percocets a day.
What?
Just to maintain the pain,
the pain level that I,
that I used to.
How many hours do you awake?
Yeah,
like,
well,
you know,
what's the other thing keeps you awake
all day.
Percocets.
Keep you awake.
Some people that go to sleep and some
people stay awake all day.
I would stay awake all day,
but after awhile I got up to take in
like 20.
Right.
And I taught day,
so I thought that was bad.
So my car,
my car,
my friend in the movie,
I say to him,
he's a,
he was in a wwe wrestler.
Luther reigns.
He's.
I said,
how many were you taking?
A day goes 90.
And he would say,
I'd get up in the morning.
My girlfriend would lay them out all
out.
It'd be like,
you know,
10 Vicodin,
10 Salma.
He taking muscle relaxers,
painkillers.
He said he,
I even take a Viagra and cialis every
morning with my vitamins.
Like when you take that voice,
it just to be ready,
you know,
is this because I'm such an asshole?
Well,
we're,
we're in like,
he's the coolest fucking guy ever.
He's amazing,
amazing.
He's got some great stories.
But I'm saying hilled up with a giant
heart.
So it tells me that a vampire with a
boner at the time he lived in Phoenix
and then Phoenix,
they have cameras,
you know,
on the,
uh,
on the freeway.
And uh,
he was on,
you know,
someone makes you go to sleep.
It's a muscle relaxer.
It makes it go to sleep.
So he said he gets a ticket in the mail.
He's like,
what the fuck is this ticket?
I never got a ticket being asleep.
He opens up the ticket and there's a
club plain as day it's fucking passed
out.
Speed is driving.
And in his corvette going,
you know,
95 and [inaudible] 65 asleep,
asleep.
He got the ticket.
He's like,
I wonder,
we get a ticket for being asleep.
God,
I don't think it really is what's going
on with him now.
He had a massive,
massive stroke.
He had a cardiac Arrhythmia,
um,
I don't know what you call that.
He had something wrong with his heart to
begin with,
uh,
all the pills and sorta live in live in
the tough life because he did a lot of
illegal drugs to,
uh,
he had a stroke and drugs.
He didn't do what he did,
like coke and everything.
Hop of it.
Right.
So,
um,
but what happens is like he,
he was getting them on the black market.
He said that he used to get a thousand
at a time.
Big,
big bottles.
Yeah.
Thousand.
Oh my.
He told me he was selling,
selling,
selling.
Uh,
he had a customer that was buying them
at $28,000,
like a week.
So he,
he had to get massive,
massive amounts.
So he was dealing,
um,
and goddamn thousand dollars worth the
pills and need a fucking forklift for
selling them.
Two guys in the NFL,
you know them to the Phoenix cardinals.
That's insane.
You know,
it wasn't a,
it wasn't a rush.
Limbo taken like 90 a day.
I was taking a lot.
Anyway.
So my friend,
uh,
luther reigns,
he ended up,
he had a massive stroke and uh,
now he's actually somehow.
So when,
when you have withdrawals from
painkillers,
it feels like you're gonna die.
And so when he had the stroke,
they said,
get his mother here,
he's not going to make it through this
and we can't pump them full of full of
enough drugs for him to get through
this.
He's gonna.
He's probably not going to make it
somehow miraculously the part of the,
uh,
the brain that is,
he is like 30 percent of his brain got
killed during the stroke.
Part of the brain that got killed was
the part that was responsible for
feeling withdrawals.
So somehow he fucking dodged a bullet.
We call him the bulletproof bad boy.
Somehow he got the bullet,
he's alive.
He has no more hangovers.
He's completely sober and he goes around
and talks to kids and churches and
things like that.
So he's doing great work,
you know.
So he lost 30 percent of his brain.
Yeah.
But somehow he's still a cognitive.
He's still,
you know,
he's still there.
He's jacked.
He's on steroids.
Yeah.
Oh,
good Christ maybe might be something.
Yeah.
So he's off the pain pills on steroids
and helping our kids.
Yeah,
there you go.
What the fuck?
Kind of a world we live in.
I love that.
One day we were eating with them,
uh,
that we're grabbing a burger or
something and he's,
he's got this fanny pack on.
He's like pulling stuff out.
He's trying to find his money,
you know,
he's like,
oh,
I'll pay for it bro.
And he's like moving in slow motion.
He's fucking drooling.
I'm like,
this guy is amazing.
What is going on with this guy?
He's putting all these different bottles
of pills on the table.
He's got like Viagara and a bunch of
other shit and carries the bottom with
them.
Yeah.
And then he put like his fanny pack yet.
Well there's Bob tools,
the many bottles and then he puts down
like a little bag,
like a clear bag of something and he's
like,
he looks at it and he grabs money clip
and he puts his money on the table and
it looks at the clear baggies like,
whoops.
And he puts that back,
whatever the fuck that was,
that was like,
that wasn't okay for him to put on the
table.
Everything else was fine.
For some reason.
He like,
oops.
Big Old stack of cash.
That's so crazy.
Oh yeah.
He's,
Oh my God.
I was like,
dude,
what if you get like your pills mixed
up,
like you're just running a ton of
fucking Viagra and shit.
Like when maybe when he was passed out
in the car and maybe he was driving with
his Dick.
Yeah,
maybe just amazing bar.
There was no blood in his brain.
It's amazing because he was,
he was dating a porn star for a long
time.
And so now he's like a born stars here.
Fucking movie.
Premiere was amazing.
Yeah.
Bigger,
stronger,
faster.
You brought two porn stars.
Two chicks making out right behind my
parents.
I was like the weirdest thing I've ever
seen in my life.
What a good guy.
He's awesome.
He's a lot of fun.
So now that he's a born again Christian,
he'll be like telling me,
look,
look bro,
now that you're sober,
now you need God.
And He'd be like,
look at this chick's tits that just
texted me.
It's like such a contract.
Walking,
walking contradiction.
He's hilarious now.
So what if anything can be done about
this crazy prescription drug crisis?
Because it seems like when you,
when you're talking about millions of
people that were on,
it was the number 8 million people abuse
it every year.
8 million people.
What is that?
Is that like three percent of the
population in the country?
Somewhere around there was pretty big.
We listen,
we ran a million people,
right?
So nine would be three percent,
Jesus Christ,
they will point seven,
$6 million in 2010.
So what is it?
Lot.
I wonder what percentage of people are
adults?
It might literally be three percent of
the population of the whole country is
fucked up on prescription pain pills.
Well,
here's the deal too.
Like we represent.
We only represent five percent of the
entire world's population.
We consume 75 to 85 percent of the
world's prescription drugs.
That's a lot of drugs because we're
America,
we do it big America.
Yeah.
So if you want to see like what,
what can be done about it?
Um,
first of all,
like just ban advertising on tv for
drugs because that just creates an
environment where people go into the
doctor and tell them what they have a
doctor as a fucking doctor,
a doctor went to school,
all you did,
all you did was watch a commercial,
you know,
that's advertised.
Do you have toenail fungus or you know,
all these stupid things.
So that creates a drug culture and idea
that there's a pill for everything.
I think that that idea is an idea that
needs it to go away.
You know,
there's not,
there is a pill for everything,
but let's not think that way.
Let's say you tired.
Are you sad?
Yeah,
let's talk about me.
Well,
and that's one thing,
but I think also just like education is
the most important thing that we can
have for anything.
Whether it's steroids,
whether it's prescription drugs,
but you say that you say that,
but yeah,
you were educated.
You,
you knew the,
all the pitfalls.
You had a brother who died of it.
You had been hooked on it yourself,
you've been doing a documentary about
all the,
all the different components of
addiction of,
of selling these pills,
and yet you still got sucked into the
web.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's how powerful it is.
So it's so crazy because you're,
you,
but you are about as educated about it
as a person can be.
I think now I am.
But back then when you were making the
documentary,
don't you think you are way more
educated than.
I was way more.
I'm educated.
I was already already susceptible to it.
I was already.
I had already been in,
you know what I mean?
So that,
that's a tough thing.
It's like if you can get,
get somebody before,
uh,
before they ever experienced it,
that's definitely a warning signs.
Maybe before you get to that point of
like reaching for a pill.
We mean other warning sounds like,
like,
like something that happens before you
actually start to take pills or do
drugs.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
was always sorta gateways,
drinking and other things that make it.
Mark.
Was it like for you to have two brothers
that have these polls but you don't?
My family is fucked up,
but you know,
I mean,
you obviously like steroids,
but I love them.
They're great,
but you don't have like the self
destructive thing going on.
Like you seem like a real generous guy.
You are a real generous guy.
Just the fact that you have this free
gym and these free seminars and I saw in
the,
in the documentary that you really love
working with kids and helping them out.
Like what is it?
Yeah.
Um,
I think I'm seeing my older brother,
I'm like,
um,
he just like his life was uh,
his life was really hard and he had to
like evade stuff and lie and like go
through all these crazy things all the
time because pills because of the pills
and then it also put a lot of heartache
and stuff on a lot of other people.
So it sort of made me go the other
direction.
You know,
like sometimes people have a parent
that's an alcoholic or apparent that
abuses them and it makes that person go
the complete opposite way and then other
times you have someone who has a parent
that's an alcoholic and they end up
becoming the same thing.
I think for me it just made me steer
clear of that.
I just remember like seeing my brother,
like hide alcohol,
like in,
in bushes and shit like that from my
parents and lie to my parents and my
parents are are as bad as awesome a
parents as you can have.
So that was always just like,
man,
it just seems like a lot of extra work
to go through.
Even if you told them that you were
having a drink,
they probably wouldn't care.
Not like they would be like,
hey,
go for it man.
They're not going to be like your buddy
and have a drink with you.
But at the same time I don't think our
parents would really care.
Especially if they were like in the
house,
they'd probably be like,
fuck it man.
I'd rather have you do an it hearsay if
you're not.
No,
you're not driving,
causing a lot of other problems,
so I just saw like a lot of,
a lot of baggage that came with all that
shit and you didn't see that.
I saw it as I completely saw,
like I said,
getting the hip to hip replacement thing
and getting hooked on pills in a way
that seemed to me to be a organic,
you know,
it wasn't like uh,
like my brother started taking pills
because he got hurt in wrestling and
then he.
But did he really,
you know,
it's like,
I don't know if he ever got a
prescription for it.
They were just passed around there are
passed around so much and in wrestling
that it was such a huge problem.
So for me I was like,
well I'm taking them legitimately.
And then it just was a snowball effect
because the doctor tells you it's okay.
It was a real snowball effect from the
squat when you fucked up your ankle and
your knee when you drop that weight.
I'd take a little bit of stuff just
because it was just unreasonable not to
like I just physically could not get up
off the couch.
You just in agony.
And then uh,
just talked to one of my buddies at the
gym.
I'm like,
dude,
like a,
I was like a need some stuff so I can
fucking move around.
So you just getting it from the gym?
I'm gonna yeah,
I'm in a lot of that.
That's where everything comes from.
That's so crazy.
You guys don't ever go to doctors say
like when I,
when I talk about the hip surgery,
I mean it felt like my,
my right side that they botched for two
years.
It felt like it was on fire and so,
I mean if you're a buyer,
you got to put that out.
Right?
So that's.
And then by the time you ready to get
off of it,
you're just so addicted.
I also told my friend though too,
I was like,
dude,
like I'm going to come back to you for
more.
Don't get me.
Don't fucking.
Don't give me any more.
So give me like an amount that you think
is like reasonable cause my friend.
What did you take a.
I don't even know.
I don't even remember exactly what it
was.
Whatever it was.
It worked pretty good though.
Just don't know.
Take two or how much you tell a
whatever.
Yeah.
This takes some for a few.
Oh my God.
Um,
I also,
uh,
would also steered me clear of a lot of
stuff,
at least as I got in a little bit older
is I met my wife,
like,
you know,
we've been married for almost 15 years
now and been together for about 17 years
and I have children.
I got a lot of responsibility.
So like even if I want to get fucked up,
like I don't have time to like go do it
really.
Right.
And you've got a lot of obligations.
Your brother didn't have any kids now
married.
He didn't listen.
You don't have any kids?
Not all kids wonder if that's it.
Whenever it's the responsibility of the
children just keeps you just having
somebody,
somebody else in my life that cares
about me,
somebody else sets a supportive and you
know,
she's uh,
as much as part of the company's success
as I am.
So all that definitely plays into it.
That's such a scary number of the eight
point 7 million people that are abusing
it and that been 2010 and not knowing
what it is in 2015.
That's terrifying to me.
That's the idea that we could be in that
state and it's sort of like something
that flies under the radar for the most
part unless you know somebody and then
you think of that person is an isolated
incident here you think of that person's
crazy or that person's doing it.
Then like you said,
doing it to themselves and you know,
like there is definitely personal
responsibility in all of this.
Whether whatever it is.
But um,
but at a certain point when things are
so addictive that people don't really
know about it or the doctors are just
handing them out like crazy for a while.
A couple years ago,
and they shut these all down.
There were pill mills,
so you just,
they call them pill mills and people
would come from West Virginia drive all
the way down to Florida just to get
pills,
you know.
So am I,
my friend that we were talking about
before luther,
he just said he would,
he'd have seven prescriptions and he's
like,
my whole day would be driving around to
different,
different pharmacies picking up
different prescriptions.
Now they have this drug database that if
you get a prescription from walgreens,
you can't go to costco and get that
prescription however nobody really uses
it.
So we have to get.
That's another way to get.
Nobody uses it.
Yeah.
Like the,
they have a plus,
you know,
the dea regulates how many of these
drugs are made and there's way more
drugs made than are actually needed.
So a lot of those fall off the truck and
you know,
different things happen where they
retained.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's built into the system is a massive,
massive,
massive money making system and
everybody's on the take.
What the fuck.
A lot of money be made and it's killing
people like vampires.
Yeah.
But we have a war on drugs.
Are there really vampires vampire to me,
as I say in the book and the film.
Is there really a war on drugs was a
warrant.
Some drugs.
That's what there's always been,
right?
Yeah.
While,
while we had a Nancy Reagan,
you know,
up there saying just say no.
Her husband's a lifting the bands on big
business that allowed the pharmaceutical
companies that grow so big.
Wow.
So this documentary then,
the newest one,
what takes place in it that you found
was shocking?
Like what?
What was going through this journey of
putting together this documentary?
Was there anything that shocked you?
Yeah,
a lot of the numbers.
But also,
um,
I interviewed this woman,
Gwen Olson went Olsen used to be a
pharmaceutical sales rep that uh,
quit when her daughter killed herself on
psych meds and um,
it's her stories just insane.
And just meeting somebody who actually
worked through the system to to know
that the people in the pharmaceutical
companies get pumped up when they have a
new drug coming out that can actually
fix the side effects of another drug
they already have on the market.
And they're so excited because I know
how much money they're gonna make off of
this.
It's just like sickening.
The whole thing is,
is disgusting and sickening and it's not
about health.
And that's what I really learned.
Worry is terrifying.
It was stopped.
Has it's such a machine that's making so
many billions of dollars.
How do you stop it and how do you level
it out?
You know,
I think people that stopped taking money
from pharmaceutical companies,
that's a big thing.
You know,
they have Donald Trump running and half
the people are like,
Oh God,
Donald Trump.
But you know,
that's something that's not going to
play into his decision making.
You know?
So if people like that,
I'm not saying him specifically,
but people like that to say,
you know what?
I'm not going to take their money.
I don't care what they say.
I'm not going to take,
you know,
it's the same thing with oil or any of
these other problems like we,
the way we fix problems is not to bribe
congressmen,
you know,
I think that that's a huge thing and a
huge thing is for regular average
everyday citizens to say no to a,
to what's going on and stop and,
you know,
write to their congressman and make us
think if all this stuff like people
wanted medical marijuana,
medical marijuana,
it didn't come about because some
congressmen said,
you know what,
I'm going to make.
This took a long time.
It took a long time.
It took a massive movement of a massive
amount of people to say we want this.
And uh,
you know,
if you at a food,
for example,
a,
everything's sort of going organic,
it's easier to find.
As hard as it is sometimes to find good
food.
It's also a lot easier than it used to
be.
So that's like Costco.
Costco is like all going organic now
because people want it.
So if people want,
you know,
a drug free society,
a society where their kids aren't dying
and killing each other over drugs,
a society where people can live in peace
and harmony and not have their families
ruined by these problems,
they can,
they can basically start that front,
you know,
just like they did with all these other
things.
That's a groundswell,
you know,
it's like something that has to start.
It just,
I just don't know how you would ever
stopped that amount of money.
It seems like the amount of money is so
fucking terrifying and that these
companies can just live with themselves.
It's,
it's so bizarre.
They can justify the production of these
fucking pills when they know that 9
million people or whatever the number is
or abusing them just in this country
with a massive amount of the drugs on
the market and pharmaceuticals,
you know,
they don't even work know they,
they had been proven.
They,
they're not proven effective.
The psych meds that we put,
we put our kids on were never tested on
kids.
So if it's not tested on a kid,
don't give it to my kid.
That's what people need to start saying,
but people say,
you know what,
it's easier for.
I put my kid on.
Everybody wants to make the exception.
Every parent I talk to says,
yeah,
but my kids different [inaudible] I put
them on adderall and now he's fine
rather than to search out all the other,
you know,
all the other options.
So then people want to try to solve
stuff with money or with or with a pill
rather than with their time.
You know,
that's a big,
big issue.
If your child has trouble in school,
maybe maybe your kid just has trouble in
school.
I fucking sucked in school.
It doesn't.
It doesn't really.
Each person is going to have their own
different thing.
They're going to be good and bad at it.
You don't necessarily need a pill to try
to solve that problem all the time.
Yeah,
and school is fucking gross.
The idea of sitting in a classroom,
especially with some fucking teacher
that's unmotivated,
sit there and you're just supposed to
absorb this fucking hours on end.
There's a lot of data that's just.
They're not designed for that yet.
They would thrive doing something in
life.
You just have to figure out what that
something is.
They can absolutely contributed to just
not care about geometry or not care
about history or not care about whatever
it is that's uninspired.
Sometimes it's the the teacher.
Some teachers get excited about anything
fun to be around.
Creativity is more important than
knowledge.
That's like Albert Einstein,
right with him,
you know,
he was always a had trouble in school,
learning,
disabled,
diagnosed with all these learning
put in a class with the kid that the
kids that eat glue and all that stuff.
Like the typical case of that,
you know,
and he's become very successful off of a
passion.
Yeah.
If you just find what it is you're
really good at.
I mean there's just.
People have different personalities and
there's different occupations.
You just got to figure out what works
for you,
but all that aside,
it just.
The sheer numbers of the drugs is what's
freaking me out in this conversation.
This almost seems like a,
like some crazy plague that no one's
talking about disease,
a disease,
a disease.
It's just spreading across the country
and that we're all kind of silent about
it until it's too late and there's no
vaccine,
it's just nothing.
That's why he was so excited to come on
the show,
you know,
to be able to talk about it and get,
get more information out there.
And then when does your film come out
to?
My film will come out in the fall.
It's not,
we haven't announced the release date
yet,
but Samuel Goldwyn is the one that's
putting it out on Samuel Goldwyn
company,
so they'll get a theatrical release and
it'll get it,
you know,
a big digital release.
So we're excited about that.
Will let me know when that happens and
I'd be happy to tweet about it and let
everybody know about it and put it up on
facebook and one God.
Damn.
So do you do these yourself?
Is this your own project?
Do you storyboard amount you like you?
And it's a little crazy.
Um,
so I did bigger,
stronger fat,
you know,
I went to USC film school when I was
trying to make films for years and we
all struggled trying to like make it,
you know,
in,
in these different endeavors,
whether it be acting or filmmaking or
anything.
So,
uh,
I was struggling for years writing a
bunch of scripts,
getting really close,
you know,
how it is,
you're really close to getting something
made.
And you know,
finally,
after awhile,
like nothing was happening and I said,
if anything in life is going to happen
for me,
I need to make it happen.
I can't be sitting here waiting for
somebody to go,
you know,
what,
I really liked your script.
I'm going to make it or blah,
blah,
blah blah.
So long story short,
a bigger,
stronger,
faster was the brain child of,
of me and my partner is Alex Bono and
Tamsin Bono.
They were um,
a couple that,
uh,
you know,
had experienced with documentaries and
stuff like that.
And just through conversations with them
were like,
fuck it,
let's go make this on our own.
So we raised all the money,
we went out and we made it on her own.
Uh,
the second film I did was called trophy
kids.
I did that with Peter Berg was the
executive producer of that and that was
a film that because a bigger,
stronger,
faster pizza,
like,
hey,
I want to work with you.
So we did a movie about crazy sports
parents.
I ended up on a hbo and that'll be
actually be available on demand on
November 17th.
That'll be coming out on demand
everywhere.
But if you have hbo go,
you can watch a trophy.
Kids,
it's called trophy kids are the extended
version is one.
We actually did a Pete Berg use it as a
part of his show called state of play.
Um,
so that ended up serving two purposes.
We got distribution for a movie we
thought was really cool and uh,
he got a pilot for a TV show.
So that's available on hbo go now.
Yeah.
Trophy kids is basically,
uh,
it's,
it's so fucking weird.
We just came here and we have this
tennis mom that's in,
that's in trophy kids and she's like,
this really like a godly Jesus Freak.
Uh,
and we just saw her at the restaurant.
We just say that before when we came
here,
I haven't seen her in like two years
since we did the movie.
But yeah,
though that film's really interesting
because parents nowadays are really
putting the pressure on their kids to
succeed.
Well,
I think they always have,
but now there's so much money involved
in sports,
getting scarier investments.
Oh,
and the kids,
the kids aren't any good.
You know,
bottom line is like if a kid's good,
they're going to make it,
you know what I mean?
Like no amount of investing in their
quarterback skills is gonna,
you know,
it'll help some kids get maybe over that
hump.
But then are you going to beat John
Jones?
Yeah.
In Reality John Jones is going to be
John John's coming out of the womb,
you know,
killing you.
You know?
That's.
Yeah,
that's the thing about the trophy kids
or the thing about parents that are
really into that.
That's always disturbing is it seems
like they're trying to live their lives,
their failures through the kid,
like they want to sort of reimagine
their own life and have some success
through,
through the kids' work.
I have a basketball dad who's like,
you know,
he'll say,
I say,
do you think you're living vicariously
through your son?
Because like,
not vicariously man directly.
I mean every shot in each move in each
go.
And that's why the referees make me want
to pull my hair out or my case make me
pulled their hair out.
It's like you're listening to this
going,
you're fucking crazy.
Your mind,
you know,
and,
and it's just normal behavior to these
people.
It's this everyday behavior.
I said,
how much did you spend on your son,
uh,
on your son's basketball career?
And he,
he goes,
I said,
I'd say two lamborghinis easy.
And who,
who measures their wealth and
lamborghinis.
First of all,
that's weird with the,
um,
did you see this story on a Todd
Marinovich?
Yeah.
Timer intervention,
which is another similar story,
but to the extreme is a great movie that
a espn did as part as part of the 30 for
30,
which I actually pitched them that be
at,
pitched them that before they did it so
that somebody else had pitched it like I
guess right around the same time.
Um,
and they did a great job with.
I thought it was awesome.
Yeah.
And it's a very disturbing story,
but it's also an,
it really highlights the problem because
here you've got a guy who's like an all
time,
great nfl strength and conditioning
coach understands the science of
strength and conditioning and,
and,
and preparing someone for a sport almost
better than anybody.
And he has a kid and he says,
you know what?
Listen,
I got fucking project now.
Turn this kid into.
And it worked.
But meanwhile the kid didn't want to do
it and it became a heroin addict.
I became an artist.
He's like,
I don't want to do it.
And I think that's what happens when he
pushed kids too much.
Like a kid kinda has to find out how
talented thing.
How talented Todd Marinovich is.
I've spoken with them several times.
He's actually cool.
Really super cool guy.
He told me he went and played in arena
football league game and he was
withdrawing from heroin so bad that he
had shit his pants and he had thrown 10
touchdown passes with shit in his pants.
Oh my goodness.
He just like,
it was so easy for me.
He's like,
footballs easy man.
It's just like,
it's just like numbers.
Don't leave them.
Boom.
Won a heisman trophy.
Didn't know he was close up for it.
I think his dad is a fucking freak man.
His Dad did an amazing job with Bj Penn
to.
Yeah,
and it's his dad's a freak man.
Is that they think they've made amends
with all that stuff.
It's just hard to do it to your own
kids.
You can do it to somebody else's kid and
make them a fucking machine,
but you're not the.
You also
don't want know what your kid wants.
I think like at a young age,
I think todd Marinovich said,
I want to be in the nfl,
but what kid doesn't say that?
You know?
Well,
not only that,
what kid doesn't change his mind when he
becomes 16 or 18,
there's a certain side of it too.
They'll look at the dad.
You know,
I was influenced heavily by my older
brother.
I wanted to be,
I want it to be like,
yeah,
I want,
wanted to be like theater and drama.
I wanted to do these other things that
are considered like,
oh,
you're a Pansy,
what are,
you know.
And,
and so those things through the culture
I grew up in was like,
you're not tough if you do those things.
We did when we were kids.
It was gay,
it was considered soccer's gay.
That's gay.
So what,
when I wanted to like,
you know,
what I had like a passion to make films
and do that stuff.
It was sort of hard to tell everybody
like,
hey man,
I'm not really,
I don't really care that much about
lifting anymore.
I want to go this way,
you know,
or whatever.
It's that,
that stuff's weird,
you know?
Well,
bigger,
stronger,
faster is available.
It's been available for a long time.
Um,
but trophy kids available right now on
hbo go and when is this new one coming
out?
It shouldn't be out in like the late
fall.
We don't have a release date,
fall prescription thugs.
When I'll,
I'll help you promote it.
I'll absolutely take you about it on
twitter and you can get ahold of mark,
mark smelly bell on instagram and
twitter,
twitter and instagram.
And big,
strong.
Fast is Chris is Chris is handle.
Would you have an instagram too?
Yeah,
at big,
strong,
fast,
big,
strong,
fast and instagram as well.
Even though I'm not none of them
anymore.
I shaved my balls for this interview,
so I appreciate it.
I'm glad you did that.
I shaved my last night.
Awesome.
Nice feeling to know that someone else
in the room shares prepped my shorn
ball.
All right,
well thank you guys.
Have a fun conversation.
I really appreciate it and very
enlightening and terrifying and a lot of
ways to.
Sure.
Thank you.
See you guys tomorrow.
Bye.
Oh Man.
Shut up.